Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und es ist Freitag und das heißt, es ist Corona Weekly, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Heute ist es soweit Pavel, das ist unsere fünfzigste Sendung zu diesem Thema. Krass oder?
Also wir sind ja ohnehin schon seit mehr als einem Jahr unterwegs. Ähm und am Anfang,
Muss ich zugeben, weil ich mir nicht so sicher, ob ihr den richtigen Titel gewählt haben mit Corona-Wikli. Das war so ein bisschen aus dem Affekt heraus. Stellt sich raus.
Ganz gut funktioniert und in gewisser Hinsicht seit ein paar Wochen, Monaten muss man schon fast sagen, seitdem wir noch diese Dienstags Clubhaus-Runde dazu gepackt haben, ist es ja eigentlich schon.
Ja, ja, ja. Definitiv.
Die Zeit, die wir da äh reinstecken, ist mindestens äh so groß wie hier in die äh Sendung. Ja und auch heute haben wir wieder so einiges zusammengetragen und.
Wir stehen vor einer.
Ganz interessanten Situation würde ich sagen. Allgemein ähm wird die Augenbraue gelupft und alle fragen sich.
Kann denn das wahr sein?
Denn wir haben einen historischen Tiefpunkt erreicht, nicht bei den Inzidenzen, aber zumindest beim Fallwert, unserem geliebten R, das geliebte R. Ähm.
Der ist nämlich äh relativ niedrig. Ich freue mich gerade, ob ob das mit diesem R-Wert, das sozusagen Teil unserer Kultur wird.
Ja
So richtig erfolgreich war ja das Verständnis von exponentiellen Wachstum.
Nicht so, würde ich sagen. Also es ist haben nicht alle so total verinnerlicht.
Ja
Wenn auch, ich meine es gibt ja letztlich zwei verschiedene Arten, mehrere Arten, wie man irgendwie die Ausbreitung äh messen,
kann so über entweder Verdoppelungs- oder Halbierungszeiten, du kannst wie die wöchentliche
ja prozentuale Veränderung angucken, was weiß ich, minus zwanzig Prozent oder.
Plus dreißig gegenüber der Vorwoche oder du kannst den R-Wert äh nehmen eigentlich,
im Prinzip alles äh haben alle Werte ja die gleiche Aussage, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass der R-Wert eben auf einen äh serielles Intervall von vier Tagen,
gerechnet wird. So, was halt aber, wenn man das einfach so macht, ein ziemlich blödes Intervall ist
weil ja 'ne Woche sieben Tage dauert und man, wenn man einfach immer nur den normalen vier Tage R-Wert nimmt man halt.
Irre Schwankungen äh im im R-Wert kriegt, dass man eigentlich nur den sieben Tage Ehrwert nehmen kann, aber das kann man halt alles wunderbar ineinander umrechnen, also zum Beispiel die.
Die Prozente beziehungsweise den den Wachstums äh Faktor äh in R-Wert umrechnen, ist dann halt hoch vier Siebtel und äh,
ja, ist dann einfach nur eine andere Skala und ähm ja und was den den.
Niedrigstand am R-Wert angeht. Also ich sehe jetzt zumindest ähm,
bei wenn man das auf der Basis der neuen Fälle berechnet
und nicht der der Meldedaten, dann waren wir in der ersten Welle mal kurzzeitig noch ein bisschen äh tiefer
Aber ansonsten ja und und die da die Zahlen aus der ersten Welle nicht so richtig äh nicht so gut aussagekräftig sind, weil da natürlich noch das mit dem testen und so gerade erst in die Gänge kam, äh aber ja
auf jeden Fall ähm haben wir definitiv den niedrigsten R-Wert äh seit
der ersten Welle äh seit wir die erste Welle in den Griff gekriegt haben. Ja und.
Das heißt noch nicht, dass die dritte Welle jetzt schon überstanden ist, ne? Wir wir fallen jetzt
schneller. Das ist eigentlich das Ding und äh habe heute schon ein bisschen rumgetwittert und es gab schon so einige Leute, die sich ein bisschen die Augen gerieben haben, so ob der sich doch teilweise sehr schnell verändernden Inzidenzen. Man ist jetzt immer lange Zeit
schon dran gewöhnt gewesen,
dass sich die Zahlen halt nur langsam ändern, ne? Es geht so langsam hoch, es geht so langsam runter und das hat ja auch alles so ein bisschen fertig gemacht, ne. Und jetzt alle so, ja wieso schnell? Das kann doch gar nicht sein,
Das war doch bisher nicht so. Das ist da da muss doch ein Haken dran sein. Wo ich dann halt meine so ja, Leute, das ist das, was wir versuchen, euch seit Monaten zu erklären.
Dass wenn man mal richtig bremst.
Es ganz schnell gehen kann. So und das hätten wir halt alles schon vor drei Monaten haben können. So und es war einfach, es lag schon auf dem Tisch, es war alles,
angerichtet irgendwie der Sahnemeritich äh lag daneben und man hätte ihn nur noch draufstreichen müssen, aber irgendwie äh mussten dann alle wieder die die Dosen zuschrauben. Ach, es war wirklich frustrierend.
Ja, wir haben also definitiv auch jetzt zumindest die längste äh Strecke oder oder sagen wir mal, längste Fallhöhe äh zurückgelegt bei äh ja.
Ja, äh Rückgang, äh Rückgang der Zahlen, also wir haben den vielleicht nicht zeitlich äh den längsten äh äh ununterbrochenen äh Rückgang, aber den sagen von der, von der Höhe her, also noch nie
äh sagen die Inzidenz so stark in einem Durchgang gefallen.
Qualifizierst du auch mal kurz. Also, was wie ist es denn gefallen?
Na ja, von, ich sage mal,
Deutschland weit jetzt von im Prinzip hundertachtzig ungefähr in der Gegend äh auf ja äh.
Die jetzigen vierzig, genau, also sozusagen um um hundertvierzig äh Gefallen.
Innerhalb des Mai.
Ja, ja. Genau.
Ne, also ungefähr erster erster fünfter, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe, vielleicht einen Tag noch davor. Also innerhalb eines Monats,
von hundertachtzig auf einundvierzig gefallen und alle wundern sich. Es ist allerdings, also ich meine, du meinst jetzt, okay, das ist jetzt die längste Strecke, die wir uns zurückgelegt haben. Wir hatten allerdings schon diese diese Fall.
Stärke, also der R war ja schon sehr ähnlich am Ende der zweiten Welle, ne. Also wir hatten ja im Prinzip genauso so einen,
krassen Fall nach unten, dann war allerdings bei sechzig Schluss.
Weil wir uns alle irgendwie in dem Moment eingeredet haben, dass ja hundert auch eine schöne Zahl ist.
Oh, ich ich erinnere mich auch noch, wie wie frustriert wir waren, als das verkackt wurde.
Ende März klar war, dass es so richtig vergeigt wurde,
und es auch klar war, dass doch wieder irgendwann eingefangen werden musste. Dass das im Prinzip in dem Moment einfach der Sommer und viele Festivals und was nicht alles gestorben sind. Und genauso kam's auch.
Und jetzt heißt es halt, reißt euch am Riemen, also jetzt ist es noch nicht vorbei, sondern jetzt ist einfach nur die Chance da
dass es wirklich vorbei sein kann, würden wir jetzt dieses Tempo halten, diese Zurückhaltung, diese diese Ruhe bewahren, diese diese diese Maßnahmentreue noch irgendwie vier Wochen durchhalten.
Dann ist richtig gut.
Wäre richtig gut. Ja ähm.
Gut, die andere Sache, was mir aufgefallen ist, jetzt im Rahmen der Lockerungen, ähm,
wie viel sagen, wie viel Schichten
Maßnahmen wir gerade haben und wie viele sagen Lockerungsschritte eigentlich in vielen Ländern noch
äh bevorstehen oder wie viel jetzt trotzdem
noch äh äh gerade aktuell an Maßnahmen da ist und das ist irgendwie immer noch also mehr im Moment mehr an Maßnahmen als im Lockdown
den wir äh damals im Dezember begonnen haben. Also in Gastronomie ist noch
äh ist noch immer geschlossen. Es gibt halt die Testanforderungen und äh ja, Einschränkungen bei Versammlungen und wie viel Leute sich sich treffen dürfen und so, das fällt jetzt, finde ich, ganz besonders auf, wenn jetzt gerade in
Berlin ja die Lockerungsschritte diskutiert werden und da gibt es
ja zum Beispiel in Berlin auch große äh äh Streit im
gerade zwischen irgendwie schneller, lockern und vorsichtiger lockern und so. Und äh ja, äh so äh ich
hatte halt ähm.
Also ich bin ein bisschen, also leicht positiv überrascht, doch von dem Widerstand äh den jetzt die Politik
teilweise gegenüber zu schnelleren äh zu schnellen Lockerungen äh da an den Tag legt. Das äh ja,
finde ich, finde ich ganz gut, äh ob's reichen wird, hm,
ja da da reden wir sicherlich gleich nochmal drüber, über weitere Szenarien, aber vielleicht sollten wir einfach mal jetzt äh, weiß nicht, die.
Zahlen mal mal trocken runterbieten, genau.
Trocken runterbieten, damit äh genau ähm ja, also.
Was die Inzidenzen,
angeht, sind wir jetzt deutschlandweit so auf einundvierzig runter nach.
Publikationsdatum. Also ja, ohne irgendwelche weggelassenen Fälle oder so. Und ja ähm null Komma sieben vier.
Und ja das,
ist zwar, also sind wir da äh,
immer noch äh von, ich sage mal, Covid-freien Landkreisen, haufenweise oder von der Situation im Sommer letzten Jahres noch noch deutlich
weit entfernt, also so vor.
Vor genau einem Jahr nach der ersten Welle, um diese Zeit, ja, waren wir irgendwo
um schon deutlich unterziehen äh in der in der Inzidenz. Also da war eigentlich.
Ähm war's da war die erste Welle schon längst vorbei.
Ja, jetzt zu den Todeszahlen, die,
auch zurückgehen, so, aber hm, nicht so stark
wie die Inzidenzen, so klar, das kommt immer mit zwanzig Tagen Verspätung ungefähr, aber selbst wenn wir die zwanzig Tage Verspätung jetzt,
berücksichtigen. So sehen wir halt bei der Zahl der Toten äh leider nicht äh diesen starken Abfall.
Bisher. So, eigentlich müsste die Kurve äh jetzt auch sozusagen nach zwanzig Tagen hätte sie eigentlich.
Anfangen müssen, genauso in den Keller äh zu gehen, wie die Zahl der Inzidenzen, aber die Zahl der Toten hält sich da äh bisher hartnäckig, äh über tausend pro Woche.
Hast du da eine Erklärung? Hast du das mal nach Altersgruppe angeschaut?
Ja, was die Todesfälle nach Altersgruppen.
Angeht. So sind es nach wie vor die Altersgruppe achtzig plus und,
sechzig bis neunundsiebzig, die so das Todesfälle ausmachen.
Und ja, die die Todesfallinzidenz bei.
Den achtzig Plusjährigen äh.
Also bei acht Komma drei, äh acht Komma sechs auf hunderttausend und.
Die bei den äh sechzig bis neunundsiebzigjährigen bei äh zwei Komma sieben, also ist ungefähr immer ein Faktor von von.
Eins zu drei ungefähr bei der äh auch bei der Sterblichkeit, wobei wir.
Bei den äh achtzig plus eben deutlich weniger Inzidenzen äh jetzt haben, aber
ja, die beiden Altersgruppen nach wie vor dominieren und das kann natürlich nur auch damit zusammenhängen, dass da immer noch
ähm ja keine vollständige Immunisierung
stattgefunden hat in diesen Altersgruppen. So selbst wenn sie jetzt geimpft sind, dauert das halt noch eine Weile und ja, da sind wir,
offensichtlich noch nicht
dass diese Altersgruppen wirklich so durch immunisiert sind, dass da oder durch immunisiert waren vor zwanzig Tagen, als sie sich angesteckt,
haben, so könnte man das vielleicht ausdrücken. Ja.
Und an sich ja müssten wir oder hätten wir einen stärkeren äh Rückgang sehen müssen oder hätte ich erwartet in den in den Altersgruppen.
Aber äh ja, da es, da wir auch keine Überblicke haben, wie viele eigentlich in welcher Altersgruppe überhaupt jetzt welchen Impfstatus äh haben.
Ist das äh halt alles nicht ganz einfach ähm zusammenzubringen, aber.
So eine neue These, die,
ich jetzt aus den Zahlen heraus mal aufmachen würde, ist hm,
Wenn man sich die pseudor Werte anschaut, also Prinzip.
Wie sich die Fallzahlen in den verschiedenen.
Altersgruppen entwickeln und äh daraus dann so etwas wie ein R-Wert berechnet,
durch jetzt einen höheren Impf,
Grad oder eine höhere Impfquote müsste sich der R-Wert in den verschiedenen Altersgruppen quasi auch ausdifferenzieren. So, das heißt, diejenigen, die,
mehr geimpft sind, müssten auch äh einen niedrigeren RWRt haben und ja, dem ist tatsächlich.
So im.
Irgendwie, also die äh äh sechzig bis neunundsiebzig und achtzig Plus haben tatsächlich die niedrigsten R-Werte und die Kinder.
Die ähm ja, null null bis fünf und fünf bis vierzehn, ähm die haben ja, die höchsten R-Werte, allerdings liegt es nur um
null Komma eins ungefähr auseinander und wenn man jetzt das,
zu Grunde legt, als Wirkung,
eben von Altersgruppe ungeimpft und äh Altersgruppe geimpft könnte man jetzt
daraus den Schluss ziehen, vorsichtigen Schlussziehen, dass die Impfungen bisher ungefähr nur null Komma ein bis null Komma zwei äh,
an RWE Senkung gerade bis bisher ausmachen, das heißt
Die Impfungen tragen definitiv bei, aber äh den Rückgang, den wir jetzt sehen, ist nur zu einem sehr, sehr geringen Teil durch die Impfungen bewirkt, würde ich,
sagen, aus den aus den Zahlen heraus, äh sondern es ist eine Summe, natürlich aus, aus Impfwirkung, äh Saisonalität, aber ich glaube, den den
größten Einfluss haben eben die Maßnahmen, die getroffen.
Worden jetzt und die aufeinander gestapelt wurden und aufeinander gestapelt wurden und.
Test, Masken, alles, Ausgangssperren, alles was wir hatten, alle Einschränkungen, Schule, Teilung oder Schließung.
Ja, Kita, ähm Kitas, äh so äh
Also und ja, wie gesagt, das das ganze Testregime ähm mit den Testanforderungen. Zwar die Tests an sich nur weniger waren, sondern dadurch, dass halt äh Leute keine Bock
keinen Bock haben auf Tests sind sie dann auch nicht einkaufen gegangen oder geht dann auch teilweise eben weniger jetzt noch aus und die meisten Restaurants haben ja auch nur Außengastronomie äh im Moment, wenn überhaupt.
Geöffnet und da ist grade das Wetter auch nicht so toll, äh dass äh ja ähm das jetzt so gigantisch genutzt wurde, beziehungsweise es liegen diese Öffnungen ja auch ersten
paar Tage zurück, sodass wir die an Auswirkungen auf die Zahlen noch nicht erkennen können oder die können auch keine Auswirkungen in den Zahlen haben.
Also das ist, glaube ich, relativ wichtig, dass man das mal an dieser Stelle mal festhält, ne.
Es wird natürlich viel gegrätscht, was alles, was äh gebracht hat und was nicht gebracht hat und ob man dieses hier oder jenes äh braucht oder nicht braucht oder ob irgendwas unsinnig ist oder nicht und es klappt sicherlich auch an manchen Sachen Zweifel
wie zum Beispiel Ausgangssperre hatten wir letzte Woche auch schon diskutiert, dass es sehr wohl sein kann, dass das seinen Beitrag leistet.
Aber es ist einfach die Summe aus allen, die derzeit ein ein.
Durchaus noch fragiles Gerüst hat und der Einfluss der Impfung wird von Woche zu Woche stärker.
Aber eben jetzt noch nicht so, dass es in sieben Meilenstiefeln vorangeht, sondern das wird wahrscheinlich dann erst dann passieren, wenn wir so zwischen fünfzig und sechzig Prozent,
ankommen, dann wird dann wird der Einfluss mit jedem weiteren Prozent, mit jedem weiteren Impftag,
immer spürbarer. Ja, also jetzt ist es ein sehr langsamer Anstieg, aber umso mehr wir uns auf Richtung hundert Prozent machen, ähm so die letzten Meter werden dann die erfolgreichsten sein.
Und dann kann man eben auch auf die Maßnahmen in zunehmendem Maße verzichten. Aber ich denke, diesen Sommer sollten wir noch viele Masken sehen.
Also definitiv und sagen, dass wir noch weit, weit davon entfernt äh sind aufgrund,
jetzt der Durchimpfung der Bevölkerung äh ja jetzt auf andere Maßnahmen zu verzichten, sondern da kann man sagen und wahrscheinlich auch erwarten.
Ja, äh das würde man jetzt alle Maßnahmen wegfallen lassen, dass die äh Infektion dann definitiv genug Leute wiederfindet, um sich rasant
auszubreiten. So, also ähm so die,
Möglichkeit einer vierten Welle, die so die Dimension der zweiten und dritten Welle erreicht ist, längst nicht gebannt aus meiner Sicht.
Das kann nochmal kommen. Ja.
Trotzdem, wenn man wenn man da in einer Prognose oder deiner Einschätzung mit impfen bringt, derzeit irgendwas zwischen null Komma eins und null Komma zwei R.
So sieht und auf den aktuellen R-Wert äh rechnet und ihn vielleicht mal ein bisschen aufroundet. Kann man sagen, impfen macht jetzt gerade den Unterschied zwischen Stagnation und Abnehmender Dynamik,
das ist gut, ja, dass wir das haben, aber das hätten wir jetzt sozusagen ohne Impfen auch nicht erreicht. Und ähm.
Kann sein, dass das jetzt äh mehr wird noch so, aber wir dürfen die Maßnahmen quasi nicht schneller wegwerfen.
Als die Fortschritte beim Impfen sichtbarer werden.
Das wäre ideal oder ähm nicht ideal, aber äh.
Wünschenswert zumindest.
Genau. UKW hat sich das gewünscht. Schöne Grüße. Ja, wollen wir nochmal einen Blick auf die Bundesländer werfen? Da gibt's ja dann doch schon Unterschiede noch, ne? Also.
Pappenheimer und äh Vorzeigekandidaten. Aber es stehen alle relativ gut da, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ja, also tatsächlich ähm haben sich die äh Inzidenzen alle aufeinander zu,
entwickelt, also die die Bandbreite der Spread ähm ja.
Ist na ja nicht wirklich kleiner geworden, wenn man irgendwie die,
Faktoren vergleicht, also Thüringen hat halt immer noch mild äh oder Baden-Württemberg ja, mit über fünfzig, achtundfünfzig und zweiundfünfzig,
haben halt eine zweieinhalb Mal so hohe.
Inzidenz ungefähr fast dreimal so hoch wie die niedrigsten Kandidaten
und ja doch also in der äh also wir hatten
zumindest in der letzten Welle hatten wir da einen einen größeren Spread sag ich mal, nämlich zwischen ja fünfundsiebzig
und knapp äh ja dreihundert nicht nicht ganz bei bei manchen Bundesländern. Also es ist definitiv
der Korridor ist,
enger geworden und ja, Thüringen, äh beziehungsweise Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat sich jetzt äh unter Schleswig-Holstein äh äh drunter gearbeitet.
Ja, also die sind so beide so bei zwanzig und Thüringen und äh Baden-Württemberg sind so ein bisschen oben, aber man muss auch sagen, bei der, bei dem er.
Den wir jetzt gerade haben, ist das halt auch in einer Woche dann schon wieder ganz anders. Also jetzt fallen die Zahlen gerade sehr schnell,
Also wenn der R so bleibt, wenn man bei null Komma sieben vier bleiben, reden wir nächste Woche schon von einer von einer deutlich entspannteren Situation,
nochmal eine Woche durchhalten. Es geht jetzt echt um wenige Wochen, ne? So ist nochmal äh eine Woche durchhalten, dann werden alle so in Mecklenburg äh Vorpommern Bereich,
und tiefer natürlich, vor allem Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Und in vier Wochen wäre sozusagen schon ideal zustand.
Nicht so kommen, ja, Spoiler, aber äh das ist jetzt quasi diese äh weil ich glaube, man muss das immer noch mal klarmachen, was null Komma sieben vier heißt. So. Das heißt, es geht sehr schnell zurück.
Achtunddreißig Prozent pro Woche, also du kannst sagen, im Prinzip vierzig Prozent weniger äh Inzidenzen nach einer Woche. Also sie halbieren sich fast, nicht ganz, aber so äh sagen Halbierung in.
In neunzehn Tagen so ungefähr. Und ja.
Das wäre schon was. Ja, das ist schon sehr gut.
Also geht natürlich noch besser, also es ist jetzt nur für für deutsche Verhältnisse sehr gut äh so.
Ja, ja, klar. Man ist ja nix mehr gewohnt.
Ja. So, also man kann im Prinzip auch äh ja,
nochmal ähm das das Ganze nochmal verdoppeln ungefähr oder verdreifachen, denn die
Geschwindigkeit des Rückgangs. Also im Grunde genommen mit einem ordentlichen Lockdown kann man in vier Wochen eigentlich fast von jeder Inzidenz auf einstellig runter,
im richtigen Lockdown.
Interessant finde ich auch die R-Werte der Bundesländer, also ähm du hast ja gerade gesagt, Schleswig-Holstein ist so.
Äh Klassen besser, weil die Ezidenzen wäre jetzt nicht Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gerade vorbeigezogen, aber äh Schleswig-Holstein hat auch den schlechtesten Ehrwert, ne? Sie sind ja irgendwie bei null Komma acht.
Geradezu schäbig. Mecklenburg kommt gerade mit null Komma sechs sechs ungefähr daher.
Brandenburg und Thüringen auch nur unwesentlich äh weniger. Also da steht noch so einiges an Wachwechsel an. Aber äh das ist das ist mal ein Ehrwert, mit dem man arbeiten kann. Null Komma sechs sechs in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern heißt da geht's gerade richtig fix.
Wie viel Prozent, wie rechnest du das um?
Ja, sind null Komma drei fünf dreifache äh also wie gesagt, das wäre dann durch äh äh also
Einrichtung ist hoch hoch vier Siebtel und das andere äh Logarithmus, aber äh im Grunde genommen geht's, geht's ja in der anderen Richtung. Wir haben ja mit dem RWW in der in der Tabelle kann man's einfach auch
ablesen, direkt in der in der Zeile, also null Komma fünf drei äh RWK, das heißt im Prinzip.
Dreiundfünfzig Prozent der Fälle der Vorwoche, ja.
Für Mecklenburg-Vorpommern jetzt.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, genau.
Okay, also da halbiert es sich wirklich, sprich, wenn es so bleibt in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, reden wir nicht mehr von der zwanziger Inzzendenz, sondern wir reden von einer zehner Incidenz. Und mal plastisch zu machen.
In einer Woche, ja.
In einer Woche. Das wäre doch mal was.
Vor neun Tagen oder so, wenn's so, wenn's so bleibt, ja.
Ja, das ist also im Grunde genommen, ist das jetzt das Szenario, äh sagen, was wir
eigentlich immer gerne gehabt hätten und zwar gehabt hätten, äh bevor die Werte auf fucking zweihundert plus äh hochgegangen sind. Hätte man das
bei einer Inzidenz von, ja, jetzt zwanzig oder dreißig gemacht, dann hätte man in einer Woche oder in zwei Wochen äh wieder einstellig,
ja, das ist eigentlich das, was wir die ganze Zeit gefordert und und gewollt haben, nämlich dass man in dem Moment, wo die Zahlen beginnen, man einfach
alle Maßnahmen äh.
Ja, alle Maßnahmen in, in Stellung bringt, also maximalen Lockdown und dann äh halt ähm priorisiert bei den Lockerungen und nicht äh bei welche Maßnahmen man einführt. Also sie,
aktuell die Strategien auch immer je höher die Inzidenz umso mehr Maßnahmen so, das ist halt
Schwachsinnsregelung, ja? Das ist halt eine, die ja
einem falschen Denken und einem falschen Denkmodell basiert, das auch in anderen Bereichen angewandt wird so nach dem Motto, naja, wenn je schlimmer es wird, desto mehr müssen wir gegenhalten
das ist halt Bullshit
in dem Fall, dass es halt zwar jetzt nicht die allerschlechteste Variante, aber das ist halt die, die uns dann eben immer äh zwei Monate oder drei Monate lange äh Lockdowns
beschert, weil man statt das sofort zu machen, wenn die Zahlen hochgehen
und das nur für 'ne Woche zu machen, ja irgendwelche Idioten,
einfach sich entschieden haben, äh die Inzidenzen so lange anwachsen zu lassen, bis man dann Monate braucht, äh um sie äh wieder nach unten.
Alle laufen auf dem Zahnfleisch und alle finden's doof und alle finden's scheiße, oh man demonstriert und so weiter und man man könnte man könnte im Prinzip alles schneller hinter sich bringen
als als sich irgendwelche Querdenker Zeit brauchen um 'ne Demo zu organisieren. Das ist halt das Bittere, ne? Und auch nie vergessen,
Wir könnten die ganze Pandemie damit stoppen, dadurch stoppen, dass die ganze Welt einfach mal zwei Wochen einfach mal sich nicht vom Fleck bewegt. Ich weiß, dass es nicht realistisch, dass das passiert, aber das ist eigentlich alles, was erforderlich ist. Danach wäre das Virus weg.
So komplett. Na ja, okay, haben wir genug geratet. Lass uns mal auf die Testzahlen schauen, wenn da da gibt's ja noch eine Perle.
Mhm. Ja, äh was meinst du mit Perleff.
Meine meine kleine Freundin, die Positiv Quote.
Hierher. Ja, ja, tatsächlich, also die Positivquote ist äh jetzt diese Woche erstmalig unter die positiven Quote gefallen
die wir in der KW sieben hatten, also vor der vor der dritten Welle.
Teil der Verzweiflung sozusagen zu schnitzen,
und dritten Welle, das ist nämlich jetzt das Tal der Verzweiflung, das war da, wo wir hier so richtig auf dem Zahnfleisch liefen. Oh Mann.
Ich nicht nicht wiederhaben. Genau, das heißt, jetzt ist der Rückgang.
Real greifbar und vor allem er ist extrem schnell. Und ähm das ging nicht so schnell bergab äh am Ende der zweiten Welle
Und dann haben wir es ja auch ne, dann hat's sich wieder umgekehrt und jetzt ist da eine gewisse Beschleunigung drin und vor allem mit fünf Komma acht Prozent Positiv Quote.
Das heißt so viel wie nächste Woche haben wir mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit ist erstmals seit Oktober geschafft äh.
Unter fünf Prozent zu kommen.
Was die offizielle Empfehlung der WHO ist, ab wo man seinen Zahlen auch gewisses Vertrauen geben kann, dass sie stimmen.
Ansonsten sind ist halt die Dunkelziffer einfach auf den Rekord und das bedeutet, wir können uns auch auf unsere Zähne Methode mehr verlassen.
Ja und äh was noch hinzukommt ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind ja auch die Zahl der Tests. Ist ja auch noch gestiegen.
Die ist leicht gestiegen um.
Hunderttausend.
Ja
Neun Prozent mehr.
Mhm. Ja, neun Prozent mehr genau auf eins Komma eins neun fünf, also eins Komma zwei Millionen, sagen von irgendwie eins Komma eins auf eins Komma zwei Millionen ungefähr gestiegen. Ähm.
Ja, wären die Zahl der Tests, die davon positiv waren, um.
Tatsächlich zweiundzwanzig Prozent gefallen ist. Und damit eben wir insgesamt dreißig Prozent hm weniger positiven Quote haben.
Und das hatten wir, glaube ich, noch nie.
Nee, das ist ein.
Doch stimmt, wir hatten den KW zwanzig. Letztes Jahr hatten wir mal so einmal siebenunddreißig und einmal einunddreißig, aber.
In KW dreiundvierzig A. Nee, ach nee, das war die andere Richtung.
Das war die andere Richtung, genau.
Fünfunddreißig äh.
Genau, also es ist auf jeden Fall sehr erfreulicher Wert. So dreißig Prozent abfallender positiven Quote. Und das macht's halt das macht die Zahlen halt auch grade so greifbar und äh mit ein bisschen äh so eine Prise Optimismus ist äh oben drauf, ne.
Disclaimer ist es, wir sagen noch nicht, alles ist gut, weil es ist noch nicht alles gut. Wir sagen nur.
Im Moment.
Wenn's so weitergeht, im Moment ist also im Moment für die für den Moment ist es sehr gut und es wäre sehr gut, wenn dieser Moment mal zwei Wochen dableiben könnte.
Drei, zwei.
Zwei, drei Wochen würde ein riesen Unterschied machen. Jetzt, wenn jetzt alle losstürmen und sagen, ah, mastenfrei, ich bin dabei. Ja, dann ähm dann ist gleich wieder Face-Pime.
Also irgendwann ist es absehbar, dass das DR-Wert irgendwann also bald äh wieder hochgehen wird.
Nein.
So, das äh zumindest hat sich das in den anderen Ländern äh äh auch.
Gezeigt, äh ja, das heißt also, wenn man so wir werden halt irgendwann ein Plateau, also es kann natürlich nicht, nicht die ganze Zeit so äh äh rapide fallen. Gut, irgendwann werden wir bald, wenn die, also wenn die
Zahlen einstellig werden, dann äh verliert aber auch der R-Wert an Aussagekraft.
Weil dann äh schwankt der halt einfach viel zu sehr, dann sind die Zahlen einfach zu klein und dann äh sind die ganzen Berechnungen ja
ein bisschen problematisch bei bei eben so niedrigen Inzidenzen.
Da schauen wir dann auf andere Zahlen. So, aber jetzt ist er noch noch sind wir nicht soweit, noch ist er wichtig und noch muss er klein bleiben.
Da schauen wir dann eher auf die Zahl der Firma covid-freien Landkreise oder wie ja das ist dann interessanter zu gucken,
Äh wo es denn dann jetzt, in welchen Kreisen es dann halt seit ein, zwei Wochen keine Fälle mehr gegeben hat. Ich hoffe, dass wir da auch bald.
Wieder sind an der Stelle.
Gut, damit es äh nicht nur so optimistisch äh zugeht, schauen wir da nochmal so ein bisschen, was so die anderen so sagen und äh sehr viel Aufmerksamkeit hat diese Woche einen Blog
Beitrag von Dirk äh Pessler äh äh gehabt, der sich äh so hobbymäßig auch mit äh Modellrechnung schon seit längerer Zeit beschäftigt. Und der hat sich mal die böse, böse, böse
indische Variante äh vorgenommen und mal so in Raum gestellt, dass die hier in Deutschland Fuß fassen würde
Also genau genommen hat sie auch schon Fuß gefasst, aber nach bisheriger Zählung sind wir, glaube ich, so bei zwei Prozent der Fälle. Das kann oder kann nicht eine, eine, eine
treffende Zahl sein, es kann sein, dass es höher ist, kann sein, dass es niedriger ist, aber das ist nun mal das, was das RKI äh ermittelt hat für, ich glaube, die KW neunzehn, also das ist jetzt so, glaube ich, oder achtzehn oder siebzehn sogar, also so drei Wochen alt,
Und das heißt, die ist da, aber sie ist nicht sie ist noch nicht dominant.
Es ist derzeit noch neunzig Prozent, alles B eins eins sieben,
und mit B eins eins sieben Kommas, wie wir ja gerade sehen, noch ganz gut aufnehmen, nur dass halt jetzt die indische Variante in dem Moment, wo sie sich jetzt, würde sie sich jetzt durchsetzen gegenüber B eins, eins, sieben.
Mit ihren Gefühlen zwanzig bis vierzig Prozent mehr Übertragungsfähigkeit.
Natürlich dann auch anders breit machen würde. Und wie wir ja eben schon auch ausgeführt haben mit der Impfkampagne sind wir noch nicht so weit, dass es dem sehr viel entgegensetzen kann und vierzig Prozent mehr Übertragbarkeit
macht dann diese null Komma eins, null Komma zwei R Vorteil, die wir haben, auch schnell wieder zunichte. Und auf der Basis hat er so ein paar Berechnungen angestellt. Hast du dir das mal angeschaut?
Ja, habe ich mir angeschaut und sieht alles sehr plausibel aus. So, also
ich müsste mir wirklich Mühe geben oder ich wüsste jetzt nichts genau warum es nicht so kommen.
Wie er äh dort äh ja modelliert hat, wobei er auch immer darauf hinweist, also
Modellierungen äh sind jetzt in dem Sinne keine Prognosen
so, sondern das sind halt eben fünf verschiedene Szenarien, die er da aufgemacht hat, mit fünf äh verschiedenen
äh Sätzen von Annahmen, wobei die Annahmen im Wesentlichen äh darin bestehen, was wir denn dagegen tun. Ja, das ist das ist mehr, mehr oder weniger die Variable. Äh plus.
Das ist halt noch so gewisse,
Unsicherheiten äh zu geben scheint ähm ja wie viel ansteckender denn denn jetzt äh tatsächlich diese Variante ist. Aber,
ein paar Fakten,
festzuhalten, die also warum ich jetzt glaube, dass das Szenario ja durchaus realistisch ist. Also erstens ist es so, dass diese,
indische Variante, also die B eins sechshundertsiebzehn zwei
äh so scheint in verschiedenen Ländern dabei zu sein, äh die Krone von B eins eins sieben als der erfolgreichsten Variante.
Zu entthronen und äh Australien und Japan, die aber beide sehr, sehr niedrige Inzidenzen haben und auch äh UK.
Liegen so mittlerweile bei ungefähr fünfzig Prozent,
B sechshundert, B eins sechshundertsiebzehn zwei. So, also
ähm die Variante übernimmt jetzt in all diesen Ländern und in UK äh müsste sie auch über fünfzig Prozent gehen,
und äh ja, wenn man sich dann anguckt, wie sch wie lange das denn jetzt gedauert hat, äh dann von
dem wo wir jetzt sind, also von den, weiß nicht, ein Niedrig einstellig so ein, zwei Prozent oder so, bis auf fünfzig Prozent hoch. In, in, in UK, dann waren das keine sechs Wochen.
So, was halt heißt, äh, dass.
Ist jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich ist, dass wir in sechs Wochen auch äh in Deutschland äh um die fünfzig Prozent indische Variante haben werden. Äh davon.
Würde ich jetzt mal ausgehen. Das heißt, Mitte äh Juli ungefähr sind wir bei äh äh bei wahrscheinlich dann bei fünfzig.
Äh neue Variante angekommen und.
Die Variante ist wohl zwischen ja sagen wir mal zwanzig und vierzig Prozent äh ungefähr ansteckender,
als jetzt die B eins, eins, sieben, das hier an sich schon mal deutlich ansteckender war, als als der Urtyp
und hat halt außerdem, weil es eben eine ganze Reihe von Mutationen aufweist, auch eine eine höhere
ein höheres Immun-Escap Potential, also Impfungen wirken halt nicht ganz so gut gegen die Variante und Impfung wirften wirken nicht ganz so gut
bedeutet in der Praxis, dass hm zum einen Leute, die nur erst geimpft sind, äh.
Oder halt mit bestimmten Impfstoffen, dass dort.
Der der Impfschutz nicht so groß ist wie gegen die anderen Varianten, also wenn ich das sich also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ich mich danach drei oder vier Wochen nach der Erstimpfung
anstecke oder auch äh ja durchaus,
mit einer schweren Erkrankung rechnen muss in bestimmten Fällen. Also diese Wahrscheinlichkeit steigt einfach an. Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die jetzt völlig.
Äh äh den Impfstoffen entkommen oder die Impfstoffe unwirksam sind, sondern äh es geht halt auf die Prozentzahlen. So würde ich, würde ich das mal äh sagen, diese Variante. Das heißt,
ansteckender und äh eben im Schutz nicht nicht so groß so. Und ähm ja, von daher
Hm ist äh das geht in diese in diese Szenarien mit mit ein
ja sieht es so aus als wenn mir in eine vierte Welle mit B äh eins, sechs, siebzehn zwei,
reinlaufen werden nach dem ersten Szenarien und die und losgehen müsste es, als ob sich das bewahrheitet ist äh,
wenn dann ja in der, in der ersten Junihälfte. So, wenn wir dort steigende Zahlen.
Sehen. Also ich sage mal, in in zwei oder drei Wochen äh müssten demnach äh die Zahlen wieder anfangen zu steigen,
so, allerdings auch nicht, nicht nur wegen der Variante, sondern einfach auch wegen der Lockerungen und dann.
Im Juli irgendwann Juli und dann.
Vor allem September August, also Juli, August, September äh sind wir dann äh wieder.
Sind wir dann in der vierten Welle. Nachdem ähm ja,
Was wir jetzt wissen und vorhersagen können, das ist sozusagen jetzt die die Vorhersage im Moment nach besten Wissen und Gewissen oder.
Ein Szenario, äh was was nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen.
Auf uns zukommt. Was ich ziemlich scheiße finde, ehrlich gesagt.
Das klingt jetzt auch nicht geil. Äh ich meine Dirk äh macht das auch sehr.
Süffisant äh gibt dann hier auch noch so ein so eine Timeline, wie er sich das so vorstellt, wie dann so die äh Gesellschaft drauf reagiert.
Mitte Juni, ja, wir öffnen weiter, weil die Zahlen sinken. Anfang Juli, wir merken, oh, jeder kommt was. Die Menschen sind bereits vorsichtiger. Ende Juli, die Politik ist soweit, Maßnahmen auf den Weg zu bringen und macht etwas Zaghaftes.
August, weil die Zahlen aber weiter steigen, sinkt das Verhalten äh der Menschen, den äh Ehrwert
Anfang September, hier werden wir kurz vor dreihundert in der Gruppe der Ungeimpften U sechzehn schon bei siebenhundert zum Schulanfang nur noch eine Notbremse,ähnliche Aktion kann das weitere Wachstum stoppen, Ende September leichte Lockerungen möglich
und so weiter. Also,
dann geht's erst wieder runter. Also es ist auf jeden Fall der Drops ist noch nicht gelutscht. Das das das müssen wir jetzt hier einfach mal sagen. Wir sagen jetzt nicht, das wird hier so kommen, sondern es ist ein Szenario. Das heißt,
Wenn die Annahmen alle so eintreffen, wie sie in diesem Modell sind und es keine weiteren wichtigen Parameter gibt, die dieses Modell nicht berücksichtigt, was ja auch sein kann. Das kann alles Mögliche passieren. Dann.
Dann würde sich das so ausspielen. Äh und von daher nochmal der Appell, also die nächsten Wochen.
Extrem wichtig. Umso mehr wir uns jetzt noch.
Zurückhalten können, auch in den Sommerferien zurückhalten können, umso besser. Damit haben wir das alles unter Kontrolle. Weil auch eine indische Variante kann man mit Maßnahmen besiegen.
Ja. Ja, was halt, was halt die größte Unbekannte auch ist oder eine große Unbekannte ist halt das Wetter.
Ähm weil ähm bei all den Studien äh wie das Wetter denn jetzt die Ausbreitung bei.
Lässt sich nur feststellen, dass,
die jetzt physikalisch chemischen Auswirkungen, also auf die Stabilität des Virus und so weiter, scheinen.
Nur einen kleinen Teil auszumachen, äh wesentlich.
Sind halt kulturelle Faktoren, nämlich äh dass sich,
wetterabhängig verändert, wo und wie und unter welchen Bedingungen sich jetzt wie viele Leute treffen. Ja, das scheint sagen dann einen größeren
Einfluss zu haben als äh.
UV-Einstrahlung oder sowas.
Als UV-Einstrahlung oder oder so was, äh beziehungsweise natürlich auch, auch Effekte, aber wenn sich Leute halt mehr
generell weniger treffen, ist es natürlich schon mal ein Faktor und weniger in Innenräumen treffen und so ist es halt auch nochmal einen Faktor plus andere Dinge, sodass
eben was man beobachten kann, statistisch gesehen, dass teilweise wärmeres Wetter.
Mehr Infektion bedeutet und äh das äh ja äh oder aber auch das wärmeres Wetter weniger Infektion bedeutet, hängt halt ganz davon ab
in welchen Temperaturbereichen sich das abspielt. Also sprich, bei, ich sage mal, zwischen dreiundzwanzig und achtundzwanzig Grad ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so viel Unterschied
als zwischen jetzt fünfzehn und zwanzig Grad, wo einfach ja
Behaglichkeitsfaktoren durch das durch das Wetter in verschiedenen Szenarien
dann nochmal ganz ganz anders sind. Und sagt Niederschläge kommen da halt auch nochmal mit.
Man weiß gar nicht, was man sich wünschen soll jetzt, ne. Irgendein Wetter halt.
Ja ja und und die Situation ist die so irgendwie meine Intuition sagt mir,
Nein, äh so, es wird nicht so schlimm kommen, aber ich könnte die jetzt mit nichts untermauern, so richtig. Äh so warum es nicht so kommen sollte, wie die, wie die Zahlen hier äh.
Warum sollten wir nicht auch mal mit emotionalen und unrationalen Argumenten kommen? Wenn das die anderen die ganze Zeit machen, können wir ja auch mal zumindest, wenn's jetzt auf den Urlaub zugeht.
Genau, alles wird gut. Wir wissen zwar nicht äh irgendwie warum äh so und eigentlich
also ja also logischerweise müsste jetzt irgendwie alles äh nicht gut werden äh so.
Aber ja, äh wir werden wir werden sehen, vielleicht kommt uns.
Ich hoffe, irgendwas kommt uns zur Hilfe, irgendwelche Verkettungen von äh glücklichen Umständen, so wie zum Beispiel äh ja, dass es über Pfingsten geregnet hat.
Äh irgendwie ja äh Gastronomie und so teilweise ins Wasser gefallen.
Ist, dass wir halt äh so ein so eine Kombination von zwei glücklichen Faktoren. Hm.
Gut, äh vielleicht nochmal einmal so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein Blick ähm,
auf ein Problem, so was äh uns gegebenenfalls halt auch noch,
bevorstehen könnte, beziehungsweise wie es sich in anderen Ländern äh entwickelt. Also kleiner Blick auf eine Insel.
Wir wissen ja, Inseln, da ist immer alles total anders und das kann man überhaupt nicht vergleichen. Ich will jetzt auch gar nichts vergleichen, will das einfach nur mal so als solches betrachten. Und zwar die Situation auf diesen Seilschellen
die ja durch ihre äh UK-Affiliation äh relativ viel und früh Impfstoff bekommen haben,
Also es gibt durchaus so ein paar Inseln äh auf diesem Planeten, die sind auch schon äh durchgeimpft, also zum Beispiel hundert Prozent, so richtig hundert Prozent komplett durchgeimpft sind die Pitkkern äh Inseln.
Okay, aber leben da nicht nur irgendwie fünfzig Leute oder so.
Ja ja, aber wir sind alle, aber wir sind komplett durchgeimpft.
Nicht die, die, die, die, die Bounty Meuterer und so.
Genau die.
Da
Also ohne.
Und so weiter. Die waren wahrscheinlich eh nicht so äh betroffen, aber das Schiff, was da irgendwie alle paar Monate anlegt, da haben sie dann mal dann doch mal ein paar ähm
paar Döschen äh Impfstoff eingepackt und das haben die sich jetzt irgendwie gespritzt und die sind jetzt einfach durchgeimpft, also um die Insel müssen wir uns keine Sorgen mehr machen. Anders sieht es gerade noch aus bei den.
Denn äh dort gibt es also eine auch eine extrem hohe Impfquote. Tatsächlich sind einundsiebzig Prozent äh das erste Mal geimpft, zweiundsechzig Prozent sind schon vollständig geimpft. Da denkt man sich so, oh, oh, zweiundsechzig Prozent, was kann denn da noch schiefgehen?
Ähm allerdings leidet das Land gerade unter einer extremen Inzidenz von zweitausendachthundert, also das war Peak. Und jetzt ist es, glaube ich, runter auf ein paar hundert.
Sprich irgendwas ist da noch los? Und äh man räselt jetzt so ein bisschen was äh da Phase ist
und ja, das Problem ist natürlich auf dem äh auf der Insel wird jetzt nicht so ein riesiger Laboraufwand äh getrieben. Also es gibt da keine Sequenzierung, keine Genomsequenzierung, keine entsprechende Überwachung. Also man weiß jetzt nicht wirklich, was da an Varianten unterwegs ist, sondern es wird so ein bisschen ähm gemutmaßt,
dort dreizehn einundfünfzig, also die südafrikante und gegebenenfalls auch schon die sechs Siebzehner, äh also die indische Variante auch unterwegs sind und dass die wohl eben dazu beitragen
dass trotz dieser hohen Impfzahlen hier keine Herdenimmunität äh erreicht werden kann. Und das mag auch damit zu tun haben.
Dass äh siebenundfünfzig Prozent der verwendeten Impfstoffe ist Sinopham und dreiundvierzig Prozent des asrasinika.
Ja, die haben nicht das gute Bayerntech. Mhm.
Nee, die haben nicht das gute Bayern-Tech und ähm aber sie haben immerhin das gute Asrasinika, aber Sinophan scheint ja nicht ganz so effizient zu sein und es kann durchaus
sein und erste Labortest sollten das auch an. Das also gerade die Südafrika-Variante gegen Sinopham noch eine Menge Druck machen kann, ne. Also heißt nicht, die Leute sind in großer Gefahr. Wahrscheinlich sind sie auch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise geschützt vor sehr schweren Verläufen, vielleicht auch vor Tod, aber,
trotzdem kann das Virus noch was ausrichten, weil weil der Impfstoff daraus darauf nicht so gut reagiert. Ja.
Die sind jetzt am grübeln, was sie machen und äh ob sie vielleicht irgendwie nochmal bei und ich mit in die Runde geben, weil das würde wohl gegen diese Varianten ganz gut äh.
Helfen. Zeigt aber nur.
Hoher Impfquote allein, ist ist auch nicht der Faktor, sonst hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie grad eben die Varianten gegen diesen Impfstoff ankämpfen,
und.
Hohe Transmissibilität, haben wir ja auch schon gelernt, jetzt mehrfach, kann sich eben auch noch in solchen Restpopulationen, Ungeimpften Restpopulationen durchsetzen.
Na ja. Schauen wir mal auf Deutschland. Wie es denn da aussieht.
Impfkampagne äh geht ja auch hier weiter voran.
Fleißig in den letzten Tagen an der Hübschheit meiner Grafiken gearbeitet.
Sieht's ganz, ganz, ganz fancy aus. Es ist wirklich interessant, also ich bin ja eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so dieser
Datenforensica und Statistiker und so weiter aber ich hab mir halt einfach mal vor ein paar Monaten die Zahlen gegriffen, weil sie so schön da lagen und weil wir das ja so noch nicht abgedeckt haben.
Und ich mache das irgendwie alles mit und äh versuche halt da äh das Richtige rauszuholen und äh auch schon viel äh darüber gelernt, wie man denn bitte seine Rohdaten gerne äh bekommen möchte
Egal fallen auf jeden Fall Grafiken raus und die ein oder andere Analyse kann ich daraus ja auch ziehen. Also wo sind wir denn jetzt? Also wir haben.
Mehr oder weniger stabile Impfzahlen. Das ist jetzt so in den letzten Wochen durch äh Christi Himmelfahrt und jetzt natürlich auch durch das Pfingstwochenende wieder ein wenig durcheinander gekommen und ruppelt sich jetzt erst langsam wieder so ein.
Im Großen und Ganzen haben wir aber sowas wie sechshundert bis siebenhunderttausend Impfungen pro Tag im Schnitt im Wochenschnitt.
Seit den letzten vier Wochen so äh gemittelt würde ich sagen.
Genau, ungefähr so seit äh Mitte April sogar, also das läuft ganz gut. Und ähm.
Ja, also ab einem, ja, seit einem knappen Monat, genau. Und ich nenne das ja vierte Phase
so. Äh mittlerweile äh nehmen die Zweitimpfung extrem zu, also jetzt gestern waren's irgendwie zwei Drittel aller Impfungen waren Zweitimpfungen und das wird jetzt noch weiter ansteigen
Werden also das äh erleben, dass wir so eine oder zwei Wochen haben, wo eigentlich fast nichts anderes stattfindet als Zweidimpfung.
Und ich hoffe, dass die Impfzentren da auch einen guten Durchsatz schaffen. Also im Prinzip alles wegimpfen, was was irgendwie geht, weil Zweitimpfung im Prinzip
eine gute Voraussetzung dafür haben, schneller zu laufen, weil da ist dann kein Aufklärungsgespräch mehr dabei, ne, da sind die Daten schon da, da müssen
nicht dieselben Formulare ausgefüllt worden, zumindest ist mir das aus einigen Impfzentren so berichtet worden. Ich habe auch Berichte gehört, dass bei der Zweitimpfung noch mehr Papierkram auf einmal aufm Tisch lag, wo ich mich frage, was, wie, warum, wieso
Aber egal, kriege ich jetzt eh nicht geklärt, ist halt so,
Ja und äh so geht es halt äh voran. Es gibt so ein paar Mysterien, die man aus den Zahlen leider nicht so ohne weiteres äh beantworten kann. Ich habe ja so eine sanfte Prognose gemacht
wie sich so die Zweitimpfung entwickeln sollten und tatsächlich.
Entwickelt sich das bei Bayontech auch eigentlich genauso, wie ich mir das so gedacht habe. Wobei ich jetzt keine äh Sophia Berechnungen gemacht habe, sondern ich einfach nur gesagt habe, ja okay gut, jetzt,
alle sechs Wochen müsste da im Prinzip Zweitimpfung, also nach sechs Wochen bis die Zweidämpfung anstehen
so und so vieles vor sechs Wochen erst geimpft werden und das ist dann sozusagen meine Zahl. Also er macht das quasi so pro Impfstoff. Und bei Astra äh habe ich das mit zwölf Wochen gemacht. Jetzt ist natürlich
alles wieder total durcheinander mit. Erstens, weil
die ähm Zweitimpffristen ja gelockert wurden und theoretisch jetzt auch Leute Asra bekommen und dann schon äh vier Wochen später ihren ihren zweiten Termin haben, was ich.
Für überhaupt gar keine gute Idee halte, aber ist halt so.
Und äh dazu kommt natürlich noch die Debatte, dass viele Leute unter Umständen auch von auf einen der beiden MR Impfstoffe ausweichen.
Trotzdem wären die MRNA Impfstoffe beide auf ihrer projizierten Linie der Zweitimpfung verlaufen.
Bleibt irgendwie Astrasinika äh flach. Das verstehe ich nicht. Also entweder müsste aber Asra Sindeka jetzt langsam mal mehr werden.
Oder die anderen müssten entsprechend mehr dazu gewinnen. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht spielt sich das auch äh die Tage dann ein, aber das ist äh sagen wir mal die einzige Frage, die ich nicht so richtig habe, beantworten können.
Ja, dann soll es ja im Juni losgehen eigentlich und äh Spahn hat ja groß angekündigt hier siebter Juni und keine Priorisierung mehr und alles wird gut, ne. Was ich auch wieder so in die Kategorie Hals versprechen
ähm unnötiges Heilsversprechen,
mit dieser unnötigen Heilsversprechen. Kann man wirklich mal sein lassen, ne? Also so dieses wir nehmen euch jetzt die Angst.
Um euren Urlaub. Darum geht's nämlich, ne? Und aber am Ende bleibt das.
Also es wäre so oder so eine schon war, fand ich das eine relativ gewagte Aussage. Und jetzt kommt noch hinzu, dass Bio-Tech Produktionsprobleme hat.
Und angekündigt hat, anders äh als ursprünglich gedacht, nicht im in der ersten Juniwoche nämlich auf einmal eins Komma fünf Millionen mehr
Impfstoffe zu liefern, sondern sie kürzen das über zwei Wochen jeweils um eine halbe Million, also eine Million weniger und schieben die zwei Wochen nach hinten. Das heißt,
Nicht nur, dass sowieso keine Termine da gewesen wären für diese heranstürmenden Leute. Nein, äh es ist jetzt sogar noch weniger Impfstoff da. Äh und auch einen nennenswerten Mengen, sodass.
Dass glaube ich dies so ein guter Mofa, aber ist egal, ignorieren wir einfach mal Herrn Spahn an der Stelle
So oder so, wie schon erwähnt, wir werden jetzt also in diese Zweitimpfung reinlaufen und danach wird's ein Run auf Erstimpftermine geben, beziehungsweise er hat's wahrscheinlich schon gegeben und dann werden sie stattfinden,
Und dann wird's aber auch besser. Also Ende Juli ist, glaube ich, so ein Fixpunkt, wo man dann nochmal nachgucken kann. Meiner Auffassung nach müsste dann so der Großteil,
auch schon mal so die Erstimpfung gehabt haben, der es auch haben wollte.
Also wenn meiner Meinung nach,
Sollte man keine Zweitimpfungen mit Astrasinika durchführen, so meiner Meinung nach, wenn die im.
Ständige Impfkommission auf Zack wäre, woran ich gerade in der letzten Woche so gewisse Zweifel äh auch noch gewonnen äh habe,
dann äh würden sie im Hinblick auf die Variantenausbreitung,
und die niedrigere äh ja Effizienz äh oder Wirksamkeit,
Astrasinika äh bei Zweitimpfungen in.
Relativ ja jetzt jetzt kurz verkürzten Zeitabstand einfach nicht den Schutz liefert, äh den wir für die Varianten.
Brauchen, ja. Das heißt, ich halte eben, ja, Zweitimpfungen mit Astra Senica äh ja, die die helfen natürlich auf auf jeden Fall, aber eben weniger gegen die Varianten.
So
Und wir wissen ja, dass halt so Hybrid-Impfungen mindestens genauso gut oder vielleicht sogar noch noch besser äh impfen, deswegen wär's dann halt eine vernünftigere Strategie.
Einfach äh Astra Sindika für Erstimpfungen zu nehmen, wo sich dann auch der Impfschutz schneller aufbaut und dann äh halt mit.
MRNA äh die Zweitimpfung zu machen, dass äh wir quasi,
äh ja, das, was meiner Meinung nach auch den besten Schutz äh jetzt vor den Varianten äh bietet.
Auf uns zukommen, weil für die existierenden äh sagen oder für ja, für die existierenden Varianten äh die sind.
Weg, also sprich der der Urtyp und B eins, eins, sieben, kann man sagen, die werden in dem nächsten halben Jahr äh mehr oder weniger von der Bildoberfläche verschwinden. Das heißt, dass wir eigentlich jetzt mehr
auf die Wirksamkeit gegen Varianten äh äh achten müssen und das passiert einfach gerade nicht,
und äh ja, was mich halt, was halt so meine Zweifel eben an der tatsächlich auch Kompetenz äh der der Stiko so ein bisschen,
getrübt hat, waren halt so Aussagen von vom Vorsitzenden irgendwie Professor Mertens, der sich halt in einem Interview äh ziemlich lapidar.
Geäußert hat äh über über Kinder und da zumindest äh Dinge in die Welt gesetzt oder behauptet haben, die man.
Die die nachweislich nicht.
Stimmen äh so. Äh das eine ist ja teil bei Kindern in Frage gestellt, das es das überhaupt gibt.
Dabei ist das halt ziemlich klar, da gibt es irgendwie Dutzende von Studien mittlerweile zu, dass man das genau sagen kann, wie viel Prozent der Kinder, nach wie viel Wochen noch an welchen Symptomen
leiden und eben ungefähr sieben Prozent der Kinder sind auch nach drei Monaten nicht symptomfrei und das ist halt,
äh so, ganz klar, ja. Und wenn dann der äh Chef äh der Vorsitzende, der ständigen Impfkommission, behauptet, es gäbe kein Lonko wird bei Kindern, ja, dann finde ich, dass eigentlich ein Skandal.
So und die zweite äh Sache äh war, dass äh,
eben auch in Frage gestellt hat, dass ja Kinder
oder ja Kinder überhaupt an Covid sterben, dass die dann auch noch behauptet, dass der Großteil äh der Fälle, die wir hätten äh das bei bei Kindern, dass die halt
mit Covid und nicht an Covid gestorben sind. Das kann man noch vielleicht ein bisschen eher debattieren.
Da gibt es dann auch 'ne Stellungnahme der DGPI der deutschen Gesellschaft für ja ist das für paddiatrische Infektiologie so.
Die sich auch nicht besonders mit Rum bekleckert hat in den letzten.
Nee, äh auch nicht nicht äh äh wirklich und äh gut, die haben da in der in der Stellung äh Name im Wesentlichen
dass bisher nur äh äh bei drei Kindern nachgewiesen ist äh oder bei bei vier Kindern äh überhaupt nur covid-neunzehn als Todesursache festgestellt
wurde von,
insgesamt aber äh ja was was waren das von insgesamt acht Fällen äh
Ja, ähm ich meine gut, was hier im Prinzip sagen ist, das ist halt halt unklar äh
wie viele davon jetzt tatsächlich an.
Ökovic gestorben sind oder sie sagen halt äh ja, einige Fälle werden noch nicht noch nicht validiert äh worden und und und. So,
mein äh Blick auf die
Sache ist, sie haben dort auch die Altersgruppen von null bis neun und äh zehn bis vierzehn äh äh zehn bis neunzehn verwendet, die ich auch nicht für optimal äh halte, sondern da finde ich die Altersgruppe null
bis bis vier und äh fünf bis vierzehn so ein bisschen aussagekräftiger, wenn man sich das da anschaut. Und da sieht es so aus, dass dort von null bis vier
ist für mich eine ganz klare Korrelation gibt zwischen Inzidenz und Todesfällen, ja. Also von denen ähm acht Todesfällen, die da aufgetreten sind, äh würde ich sagen, liegen.
Fünf oder sechs äh passen halt perfekt äh auf äh die Inzidenzen, die sind halt zu dem Zeitpunkt passiert als auch die Infektion in die in die Höhe.
Und äh ja, an etwas anders sieht's tatsächlich bei fünf bis vierzehn äh aus, da.
Also es scheint mir so zu sein, dass das.
Unterschiede gibt, wie halt die ganz kleinen Kinder auf Covid reagieren und die mittlere Altersgruppe auf auf Covid reagiert. Und die schmeißen halt beide Altersgruppen auch noch so,
eben äh zusammen durch ihre äh Alters äh Einteilung, äh die sie da machen, so plus, wenn unterm Strich.
Macht es jetzt auch keinen großen Unterschied, ob das jetzt drei oder zehn äh äh Kinder äh gewesen sind, ja, das sind immer noch extrem kleine Zahlen am Ende des Tages, aber hochgerechnet,
Wenn man jetzt alle Kinder durchinfizieren würde, selbst wenn's nur drei,
gewesen wären so. Dann äh ja äh führt das äh würde ein Durchinfizieren der Kinder, selbst bei den dreien äh würden halt äh zwischen, ich sage mal dann.
Ungefähr mindestens zwanzig Kinder jetzt noch noch an Covid sterben, wenn wir sie nicht impfen,
Kann man sagen, naja gut, was sind schon zwanzig Kinder äh ja äh bei,
wie achtzigtausendneunzigtausend Toten, die insgesamt äh gestorben sind,
Aber äh ja, was die DGPI da macht, äh halte ich eher für eine unzulässige Verharmlosung äh auf einer Datenbasis, die das nicht hergibt.
Ja so das ist mein Take äh äh.
Zwischendurch.
Auf die auf die ganze Geschichte. Und ja, man kann da, man kann darüber reden, wie gesagt, ob
aber äh so äh das, was was dort äh in der Stellungnahme behauptet wird, das ist
aus meiner Sicht nicht durch die Studienlage äh gedeckt. Ja und sie sind auch sehr vorsichtig in ihren in ihren Aussagen, aber äh trotzdem äh ja
Also die Zahlen, äh die sie da haben, auch sie vergleichen das dann mit Grippe und Unfalltoten noch äh an an der Stelle und,
ja ähm also ja, schwierig,
jeden Fall äh so muss ich, muss ich sagen, so äh habe ich, als ich mir dieses Mertens äh Interview angehört habe, äh so wie gesagt, also das
kann ja eigentlich nicht wahr sein, ja, dass äh irgendwie der Vorsitzende so äh salopp
daherquatscht, ja? Über Dinge, von denen er keine Ahnung zu haben scheint so, das war ein bisschen schockierend für mich, ehrlich gesagt.
Merk schon, wo war das Interview?
Ähm das war Phönix. Äh.
Okay, dann dürft's davon ja eine Aufzeichnung geben, die man sich vielleicht noch verlinken kann, ne.
Oder so oder oder Fokus. Ja, ja, habe ich, ich habe, ich habe die getwittert, ja, kann man das verlinken.
Gut, ich wollte ja auf Kinder eigentlich gleich noch äh kommen im Rahmen der der äh Impfstoffe, aber jetzt haben wir das schon mal abgehandelt. Äh lass mich nochmal kurz äh die Klammer zumachen, um wie es denn so mit der Impfkampagne weitergeht.
Ähm noch eine Sache.
Es gibt einen aktuellen Report beim RKI, in dem auch nochmal neu ermittelt wurde durch Umfragen, wie denn so die Impfbereitschaft so aussieht in Deutschland.
Und ich fand die Zahlen eigentlich ganz erfrischend, weil da hatte ich jetzt mit schlimmeren äh gerechnet. Äh laut dieser Umfrage und dem, was das RKI da
veröffentlicht hat.
Wollen sich wohl in Deutschland zweiundsiebzig Komma sechs Prozent der Bevölkerung auf jeden Fall impfen lassen, also die Betonung liegt hier auf, auf jeden Fall, dass es sozusagen die Formulierung, die da angekreuzt haben.
Und auf keinen Fall wollen sich äh vier Komma sechs Prozent nicht impfen lassen. Vier Komma sechs Prozent.
Das klingt jetzt nicht wie die Revolution vom Reichstag, wenn du mich fragst. Ähm das ist eine Zahl damit kann ich leben, so mit fünf Prozent.
Bleiben als Differenz. Zweiundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent, die man vielleicht nochmal überzeugen sollte.
In irgendeiner Form der ein oder der anderen Seite äh hintendieren, die was weiß ich, ängstlich sind oder verängstigt wurden, falsch informiert sind oder vielleicht auch gute Gründe haben. Kann ja auch sein, aber,
viele gibt's halt nicht und wenn man jetzt mal sagt, okay gut, dann teilen wir uns die. Ja, die Hälfte.
Also man könnte ja auch sagen, man nimmt diese zweiundzwanzig äh Komma acht Prozent und und und teilt sie dann entsprechend diesem Verhältnis von zweiundsiebzig äh zu zweiundsiebzig Komma sechs zu vier Komma sechs auf, aber sagen wir mal die Hälfte, ne. Hätten wir eine Impf
quote, eine theoretische Impfquote, die wir erreichen könnten von vierundachtzig Prozent. Was ganz gut wäre.
Ja, das wäre so wahrscheinlich grade so an der Grenze äh in der Gegend äh der ja, Herdenimmunitätsquote, wobei je nach je nach Virus.
Na ja, nicht vergessen, dass da auch noch Leute dazukommen, die sich auch schon infiziert haben. So und das sind dann bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt ja auch nicht so viel, so wenige.
Hab jetzt grad so 'n Blick verloren, was haben wir jetzt bisher in Deutschland angehäuft, offiziell, angemeldeten, ohne, ohne Dunkelziffer?
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, haben wir viertausendvierhundertzwölf äh insgesamt pro hunderttausend. Das wären dann.
Vier Komma vier Prozent.
Vier Komma vier Prozent in Deutschland, die offiziell mal via PCR Test als infiziert gemeldet worden sind. Das kann man eben vielleicht nochmal eine Dunkelziffer überhelfen.
Mindestens drei.
Mindestens drei. So heißt, wir haben also mindestens zwölf Prozent der Bevölkerung, die sowieso schon Virus hatte.
Eher so, ja, dreizehn, vierzehn, fünfzehn Prozent.
Zwölf bis fünfzehn Prozent. So und plus vierundachtzig Prozent Impfquote soll auch schon bei neunundneunzig Prozent. Okay.
Gibt's natürlich andere Überlappungen und so weiter, aber auch von diesen vier Komma sechs Prozent, die sie auf keinen Fall impfen lassen wollen, haben's bestimmt schon welche gehabt. Und äh auch von diesen zweiundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent. Also das
das ist sozusagen nochmal etwas, was dazu kommt. Und wenn ich jetzt mal locker mal rangehe, sage ich mal, vierundachtzig Prozent äh Bereitschaft.
Plus nochmal sechs Prozent sowieso schon erwischt worden. Kommen wir bei neunzig Prozent raus.
Ist keine Prognose, ich sage nur diese Angst.
Dass wir das Problem durch mangelnde Bereitschaft nicht lösen können, die habe ich jetzt so nicht.
Ich habe da eher eine eine positive Erwartung. Wir können das hinbekommen. Wir können das, wir können das schaffen, ja? Die Leute sind irgendwie dabei. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich finde diese Zahl von zweiundsiebzig Komma sechs Prozent.
Die sich auf jeden Fall impfen lassen wollen, ne.
Weiß nicht genau, wie die Aufteilung war, aber wahrscheinlich wird so was gewesen sein, wie auf jeden Fall äh eher schon,
weiß aber nicht oder eher nicht und weiß aber nicht und auf gar keinen Fall, ne? Habe ich jetzt nicht gesehen, aber es ist jetzt gerade meine Vermutung, weil nur diese beiden Dinger kannst du ja nicht,
na ja und da ist dann also auf jeden Fall noch was zu bewegen
zumal da ging ja irgendwie heute, ich weiß nicht, hast du das gesehen, da ist wieder so ein so ein, so ein, so ein Clip aus irgend so einem Social Network, da weißt du halt auch immer wieder nicht, äh woher das kommt, aber ich fand das irgendwie trotzdem gut, irgend so ein Kommentar, wo jemand meinte, ja, also ich kriege so langsam das Gefühl, hier diese ganzen
Warner, die die wollen ja irgendwie nur Geld machen und irgendwie sind schon so viele Leute geimpft worden, dass irgendwie nix passiert so. Vielleicht stimmt das ja auch alles gar,
also kann durchaus sein, dass er auch ein paar jetzt wieder aufwachen und endlich mal sehen, was für ein Unsinn da die ganze Zeit äh verzapft wird.
Und ähm ja, Abteilung, alles wird gut.
So in wie inwiefern jetzt? Ich ich hab's noch nicht, ich hab's nicht verstanden, worauf du hinaus wolltest.
Die Angst, die viele treibt, ja, dass durch diese ganze Verunsicherung, durch diese Querdenker, durch diese esoteriker, diese ganzen
blendeten, die einfach andere Leute, die sich sehr wohl vielleicht impfen lassen würden, wenn sie nicht die ganze Zeit unter so einer Peerpreser stehen würde oder unter so einer media oder Social-Bubble
Presser stehen würden. Dass die sehr wohl zu gewinnen sind und dass sogar die, die dem ohnehin nicht anhängen
in einer überwältigenden Mehrheit. Dreiviertel sind einfach da und sagen, nee, ich weiß, wie der Hase läuft. Wir lassen uns hier impfen und so weiter. Ich will, dass das jetzt vorbei ist. Äh das läuft schon.
Okay, also ganz offensichtlich ist die Vollpfostenquote in Deutschland niedriger als die Vollpfosten äh die halt auch manche politischen Ämter äh äh bekleiden äh so glauben.
Ja, wir haben eine niedrige Vollpostquote, das kann man, kann man so festhalten.
So, aber äh weil eben äh grade viele dieser Vollpfosten in der Politik sitzen oder sehr laut sind
so hat man das Gefühl, äh ja äh es gebe mehr davon, aber in Wirklichkeit, ja.
Ist das gar nicht so.
Äh
UKW, sind gut informiert und, und, und, und wissen, was ich.
Genau, also also vier, vier Komma sechs Prozent äh äh Vollpfostenquote plus irgendwie X äh so.
So sieht's aus.
So, kommen wir zu den Meldungen aus der Medizin und der Wunderwelt der Virologie. Ähm ein paar Nachrichten,
Zunächst einmal, wo wir schon über Kinder äh gesprochen haben, gibt's ein paar gute Nachrichten. Also Biotech äh ist heute tatsächlich,
für Kinder, also von Kinder ist gut, also für zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährige zugelassen worden von der EMA,
Nachdem das ja in den USA schon durch war und dort schon seit einiger Zeit die Impfungen laufen ähm ist das jetzt einfach abgesegnet worden
man kann davon ausgehen, dass äh auch wenn du Zweifel an das Trikot hast, äh an der Stelle die Bundesregierung scheint da auf jeden Fall sehr entschlossen zu sein und die ist ja am Ende dann nicht unbedingt entscheidend.
Ne, sondern wer ist eigentlich entscheidend? Es ist oder ist RKI, ich glaube das ist PI, ne? Und die.
Das wird kommen. Wir werden einfach Impfungen für Kinder sehen. Das ist super.
Moderner wiederum hat äh auch.
Bekannt gegeben, dass sie ihre Tests jetzt abgeschlossen haben, so wie das Biotech Faiser vorher auch schon gemacht worden, ne. Ähm dass auch ihr Impfstoff, ihr MRNA, Impfstoff wenig überraschend,
auch diese hundert Prozent Wirksamkeit hat, also man hat halt.
Zwölf bis Fünfzehnjährige oder in dem Fall waren's zwölf bis Siebzehnjährige in den USA äh geimpft, zwei Drittel haben eine richtige Impfung bekommen, ein Drittel war Placebo und auch hier hundertprozentiger Schutz vor Erkrankung.
Also vor schwerer Erkrankung und äh dreiundneunzig prozentiger Schutz vor irgendwelchen Symptomen. Ne, also es gab durchaus Infektionen und
was weiß ich und dann wurde halt irgendwie gehustet oder keine Ahnung, was da alles war, so diese,
Symptome eben und äh aber auch das eben bei dreiundneunzig Prozent der Teilnehmer nicht.
Es gab die üblichen Impfreaktionen, wie sonst eben auch, Kopfschmerzen, Müdigkeit, Muskelschmerzen, Schüttelfrost, all diese ganzen Sachen sind aufgetreten, aber das ist ja auch normal und damit äh rechnet man und da äh stört man vor allem nicht von
Ja und von daher gehe ich mal davon aus, dass auch moderner hier relativ schnell nachrücken wird und wir dann quasi mit beiden Impfstoffen in diese Altersgruppe,
vorangehen können,
Außerdem haben sie noch äh gesagt, dass sie auch in ihrer Studie für Kinder von einem halben bis elf Jahren in Phase zwei sind.
Und grundsätzlich habe ich so den Eindruck, dass die da sehr zuversichtlich sind, dass es da auch nicht so sehr viel anders aussehen wird. Dafür ist einfach MRNA äh zu gut.
Ja, also Amazon die Ergebnisse sind eigentlich wie erwartet, alles andere wäre eine Überraschung,
gewesen, aber Überraschungen können natürlich auftreten, aber insofern äh ja äh weiß man halt generell, dass Impfstoffe, die also es gibt nur ganz wenig Impfstoffe, äh die
bei Kindern irgendwie man nicht impfen kann oder oder oder soll, sonst ist eigentlich alles alle Impfstoffe eigentlich auch für für Kinder sogar wunderbar
geeignet. Äh sind halt nur
unter Umständen andere Dosierungen, niedrigere Dosierungen, die man für die ganz Kleinen so, aber ansonsten ist es, wie gesagt, wer's, wär's eine große Überraschung, äh, wenn das, wenn die Ergebnisse anders.
Werden, aber ja.
Meldung gab's ähm um Sputnik V. Da äh sind Tests in Argentinien durchgeführt worden. Gab's eine Studie, die von Forschern, von argentinischen Forschern äh gemeinsam mit ähm.
Diesem russischen Direktinvestitionsfront.
Durchgeführt wurde. Da fragen sich alle, was hat denn bitte der russische Direktinvestitionsfront damit zu tun? Das ist der offizielle Vertriebskörper von Sputnik V.
RDIF abgekürzt.
Ich weiß ja nicht viel drüber, aber das ist sozusagen so eine Entität in Russland, die mehr oder weniger ich sage mal, die Vermarktung,
nationaler Assets äh vornimmt und da gehört halt auch dieser Impfstoff dazu.
Ähm ich kann jetzt die.
Nur erwähnen, ich habe das nicht durchgelesen, habe da kann das nicht beurteilen, äh wie sehr man dem trauen kann, aber sie sind der Meinung
das mit V, geimpfte Leute in äh in Argentinien äh das fünfundachtzig Komma fünf Prozent der Personen nach vierzehn Tagen nach der ersten Dosis äh
wirkungskräftige Antikörper gegen P eins Variante entwickelt haben.
Ja, also warum ich das erwähne, ist eigentlich nur egal, wohin man äh schaut, die.
Emma na Impfstoffe und auch die Vektor Impfstoffe scheinen grundsätzlich derzeit noch.
Gut gegen alle Varianten, die verbreitet sind zu.
Jetzt indische Variante ist ein neues Ding und irgendwo aufm ausm Augenwinkel habe ich jetzt irgendwas von einer Thailand-Variante äh gelesen, das glaube ich aber auch erst, wenn ich noch ein drittes Mal sehe, weil in Thailand war eigentlich bisher so wenig los. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich da eine Variante hätte entwickeln sollen. Das war wahrscheinlich auch nur wieder so ein
blöder Spruch.
Ja, ich, ja, aber ich würde, würde sagen,
dass diese Studie äh ja mit einer gewissen Vorsicht äh zu genießen ist oder diese Reutersmeldung, äh sagen wir mal, äh so, weil
Ich hab, wir haben auch nicht in die Studien, also ich hab die Studie selbst haben sie nicht verlinkt, wenn ich das richtig
sehe, dass das gut, das kann jetzt ein Problem von von Reuters sein, aber ja,
Also gut, ich würde es jetzt äh also es gibt sehe jetzt auch keinen Grund, warum äh Sputnik, V da jetzt nicht,
wirksam sein sollte, also insofern, ja, kann, kann gut sein, dass das, dass, das stimmt. Die
Ergebnisse, die sie dort haben, aber so der ganze Kontext macht mich halt schon so ein bisschen, ja, vorsichtig äh bei den Dingen auch natürlich.
Das ist natürlich gewisse Interessen gibt und dass wir halt wissen, dass halt dann schon Moskau oder dieser ähm dieser Fonds, der hat sich
ja in der Vergangenheit, teilweise auf Twitter nicht damit hervor getan
besonders ja wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse zu liefern, sondern die haben dort
äh auch äh sagen, bestimmte Fehlinformationen gestreut und versucht, eben bayerntech schlecht
zu machen, äh so in in ihren.
Gegen ein Jahr und das ist, weiß ich nicht, das also insofern äh ja, dass das Gebaren dieses äh russischen äh Investitionsfonds äh da
ähm halte ich für teilweise inakzeptabel wie die öffentlich kommuniziert haben. Insofern ja sagt das jetzt vielleicht nicht direkt über die Studie aus, aber zumindest ist bei der Quelle
höchste Vorsicht geboten.
Dass äh es ist sicherlich richtig in dem Zusammenhang, können wir auch vielleicht gleich nochmal sich nochmal eine andere Meldung vor, weil's nämlich jetzt hier gerade ganz gut passt. Ähm,
mitbekommen hast, aber es gibt ja so eine eine super skurrile Desinformationskampagne,
äh auch solche äh Links nach Russland zu haben scheint. Und das ist so eine gemeinsame Recherche von Netzpolitik Punkt org und dem ARD-Magazin Kontraste. Das Ganze äh ist ausgelöst worden
dadurch, dass sich deutsche YouTube Influenza oder einer im Spezifischen gemeldet haben, äh die so E-Mails bekommen haben, wo ihnen Geld
dafür geboten wurde, dass sie bestimmte Informationen über Biotech Impfstoffe verbreiten.
Und ähm das Ganze ging von so einer Londoner PR-Agentur aus
den schönen Namen Fatze klingt FAZI, also Fassi oder keine Ahnung und äh nach ein bisschen recherchieren kommt man das äh kommt man drauf, dass da eigentlich so eine
ähm
merkwürdige Werbeagentur namens äh et now kommt, die halt damit preist äh native Werbungsformate zu bringen und wir wissen alle, was das heißt, native Werbeformate ist so ein Codewort für
Wir tun so als als wäre das jetzt hier der der original Content des jeweiligen Kanals. Obwohl wir das im Prinzip alles geskriptet haben und nur fürs Vorlesen und für das Darreichen quasi bezahlen.
Das ist so ein Problem und da sind sie mal so ein bisschen hinterher gegangen, das läuft dann total ominös, den ist also per E-Mail das angeboten worden, wenn sie sich dann darauf meldest, dann kriegst du irgendwie so ein Passwort, wo du dich dann
Auf dieser äh Londoner PR Agentur Webseite auf irgend so einer Unterseite einloggen kannst, wo dann dir der der konkrete Deal angeboten wird
Und die Informationen, die dort dann verbreitet werden sollen und das haben wir auch durchaus welche angenommen. Da gibt's Beispiele von Leuten aus Brasilien und äh noch online, habe ich jetzt gerade vergessen,
also dann auf ihrem YouTube-Kanal, irgendwelchen Gamer, weißt du, mit was weiß ich, Millionen von Followern, die dann einfach diesen Unsinn äh verbreiten und welchen Unsinn geht's?
Es soll behauptet werden, es gäbe eine sehr große Zahl von Impftoten nach der Verabreichung von
ja? Ähm da gibt's so eine Tabelle, wo so eine vermeintliche Zahl der Impftoten äh abgebildet ist. Und es bezieht sich tatsächlich auf Deutschland
und ähm da wird also davon äh geredet, dass halt bei einer Million Impfdosen, die verabreicht werden, irgendwie
ja knapp dreißig Menschen in Folge einer Impfung mit Bier und gestorben sein,
So und äh wie sechs bis sieben Menschen durch ja.
Jetzt ist es nicht komplett aus der, aus der, aus der Luft geholt, sondern es gibt diese Zahlen tatsächlich nur ist die Darstellung halt falsch,
Weil das ist nichts anderes als eine Veröffentlichung der Pie-Daten.
Haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt, die Abkürzung, es ist äh paar ehrliche Institut, die halt für Impfstoffe zuständig sind in Deutschland. RKI ist für die Infektion zuständig. Das PEI ist für.
Die die Impfstoffe zuständig und das ist einfach die Statistik die der Zahl der Gestorbenen Nachimpfung,
Also nicht wegen Impfung, sondern einfach Leute, die geimpft wurden und danach halt gestorben sind, weil Leute sterben halt so. Das ist halt so. Und wenn irgendwie ganz viele Millionen Leute äh geimpft werden, dann gibt's natürlich auch Leute, die danach sterben. So.
In England ist auch derjenige, der Erste, der eine Impfstoff bekommen hat, der weiß noch, wie der hieß? Der hieß ja irgendwie äh.
Ja
Tatsächlich. Der ist jetzt auch gestorben. Ja, warum? Ja, weil er alt ist. Sowas passiert. Alte Menschen sterben.
Ja, wir hatten das auch schon mal vor äh Wochen hatte ich mir dieses
Thema äh dann etwas genauer angeguckt und tatsächlich ist es so, wenn man die Zahl der nach
Impfung oder im zeitlichen Zusammenhang mit Impfung Verstorbenen,
gemeldet wurden, sich sich anschaut, dann sind das deutlich weniger
als eigentlich in der Altersgruppe hätten, äh sagen, eines normalen äh Todes sterben müssen. So, ja, das heißt, wir hätten eigentlich noch äh sagen, oh aufgrund der natürlichen
Sterbetafeln hätten wir viel hätten wir das drei bis fünffache eigentlich an Toten haben müssen.
Du meinst das impfen könnte auch das Leben verlängern.
Na ja, ich äh.
Ne, ich ich führe das darauf zurück, äh dass halt ähm sagen.
Diejenigen, die zuerst geimpft,
worden sind, wahrscheinlich äh so im im Schnitt eine etwas gesündere Gruppe darstellt, weil man wahrscheinlich bei vielen Leuten, die so, ja,
äh sowieso schon, ich sage mal,
so schwer krank waren, äh dass dass sie irgendwie in der Krise waren, hat man wahrscheinlich darauf verzichtet, äh denen
auch noch eine Impfung äh äh zu verabreichen, beziehungsweise ja, bei bestimmten Erkrankungen oder so, die du gerade hast
äh kannst du halt auch nicht, nicht geimpft werden. So, das war deswegen meine These, äh dass äh sagen, ja, die.
Die Geimpften, eine,
eine etwas äh ja gesünderen Teil der der Population darstellen, als als die Gesamtpopulation. Das ist die eine These oder,
bis in vielen Fällen äh äh der Tod äh gar nicht als im Zusammenhang mit der Impfung,
stehend gemeldet wurde, weil halt ganz offensichtlich klar war, dass es äh dafür andere Ursachen gab, ja.
Diese beiden Dinge zusammen sind für mich die Erklärung äh warum äh die Zahlen so niedrig sind, ja.
Plausible Ansätze,
also auf jeden Fall diese Kampagne ist da und äh warum ich das erwähne, ist, glaube ich, auch klar. Mir geht's halt da drum, dass ähm warte mal.
Mir geht's halt darum, dass.
Man bei all diesen Berichten, die so verteilt werden und das Netz ist ja auch voll davon, auch wann wann immer ich irgendwie was zur zur Impfkampagne äh twittere, dann kommt dann doch wieder irgend so ein
und dieses und jenes und guck mal hier und hier ist irgendwie ein komischer Link und dann klickst du irgendwie zwei, drei Mal, dann bist du schwer bei irgend so einem Reitschuster oder Querdenker äh äh Unsinn äh äh wieder aufgelaufen. Das ist immer immer der selbe Geschichte. Immer irgendwas wird rausgezogen und es wird immer übertrieben dargestellt,
sehr schwierig. Also ich kann dir ganz gut ignorieren, ne. Es ist bloß manchmal ein bisschen schwierig. Zwischen denen.
Und Leuten, die legitime Zweifel an irgendwas haben oder die vielleicht tatsächlich irgendeinen interessanten Punkt haben noch zu unterscheiden.
Gerade wenn die Leute danach so skurrile.
Haben so mit ohne weitere Informationen und ohne Kontext und so weiter. Ich studiere da manchmal wirklich erstmal so äh eine Minute die Timeline und gucke mir mal an, was die sonst noch so für ein Zeug äh von sich geben, um es so ein bisschen einordnen zu können
Na ja okay, ist auf jeden Fall nicht einfach. Kurz gesagt, solche Desinformationskampagnen, das mag jetzt eine Ausnahme sein.
Aber es zeigt halt auch.
Gibt hier auch Interessen, die nochmal jenseits nur der Bekämpfung der Pandemie sind. Da gibt's schon so Gruppen, die vielleicht auch ein Interesse daran haben, irgendeinen Impfstoff besser dastehen zu lassen. Und wenn man halt hier gegen ausgerechnet gegen den Impfstoff, der
zweifelsohne derzeit weltweit eigentlich am besten dasteht, kann man ja, glaube ich, mal so festhalten. Äh angeht, dann naja, dann muss man sich da,
Also ich wundere mich da nicht drüber,
wundere mich über die krassen Methoden und ich wundere mich auch ehrlich gesagt über diese Influencer, die wirklich so schamlos sind und hier Kohle einstreichen und auf der anderen Seite einfach uns allen.
Leuten Probleme bereiten dadurch.
Einen Bärendienst tun Plus. Also diese,
Desinformationskampagnen. Ich finde insbesondere,
so diese diese Hinweise, die dann wohl auch kamen, dass dass man das verschleiern soll, also das, sagen wir mal, dass den Begriff sponsort
vermeiden soll und verwenden sie keine Wörter wie Werbung
Video und so weiter in ihren Beiträgen, Geschichten und Videos oder tun sie so als hätten sie die Leidenschaft und das Interesse an dem Thema, präsentieren sie das Material, als ihre eigene unabhängige Sichtweise.
Finde ich alles schon ganz schön perfide und äh ja, es ist auch äh unzulässig, sagen wir mal, es gibt.
Nicht gewisse Gesetze dagegen äh sondern gegen irreführende äh äh
Werbung, also in den meisten Ländern ist es nicht okay, aber offenbar scheint da die Höhe der Strafandrohung äh noch nicht noch nicht hoch genug,
zu sein und ich wäre schon dafür, dass man mal guckt, äh was man denn da irgendwie gesetzlich noch,
tun kann, um ähm zu verhindern, dass Leute für Geld ähm Fehlinformationen verbreiten.
Ja, schwieriges Feld, ne, weil du natürlich dann auch voll in den Journalismus äh sozusagen reingrätscht, äh der ist ja im Prinzip auch für Geld macht
Okay, er wird nicht explizit jetzt nur dafür bezahlt, diese falsche Information rauszubringen. Ist schon was anderes. Das muss man halt klar trennen
insofern bin ich da ganz bei dir, weil das eigentlich eh nicht aufgehangen sein sollte, wie eben
so versteckte Werbung an sich, ne, aber hier halt nicht Werbung, sondern eben auch nochmal ganz konkret.
Falschinformation und dann auch nochmal im Kontext Pandemie da sind schon mal so so zwei level ups die man da ziehen könnte äh um's wirklich ein bisschen,
gefährlicher zu machen auf diese Pfade zu schreiten.
Ja, ich meine, die Hürden werden natürlich,
notwendigerweise sehr hoch oder müssten halt sehr hoch sein, das heißt, man muss den Leuten dann wirklich nachweisen, dass sie es äh eben aus äh ja kommerziellem Interesse
getan haben und dass sie wussten oder hätten wissen
können, äh dass es sich um eine Fehlinformation handelt, so dass wahrscheinlich die Zahl der Fälle dann auch nicht sehr hoch wäre, in denen man das wirklich nachweisen kann, aber
ich würde sagen, so einen Fall.
Wie hier, wo dann auch eine Agentur das ganze tut, plus die Agentur, finde ich, die gehört äh eigentlich dicht gemacht, die äh irgendwie andere Leute zu Straftaten anstiftet äh gegen Geld, also ich,
finde, das kann kann nicht einfach, das ist kein Kavaliersdelikt. In meinen Augen, sondern das ist schon,
schwere, also Schwerkriminell, weil
denken immer so, ja, Informationen und so, das ist ja harmlos, da wird ja niemand jetzt irgendwie erschossen oder mit einem Knüppel über den Kopf gehauen, aber es können halt trotzdem jede Menge Leute sterben, insofern
sind, sind wir, glaube ich, ähm ja, speziell auch,
unserer westlich freiheitlichen Sicht äh sind wir da an manchen Stellen glaube ich zu liberal äh so
ähm das ist mittlerweile nach vielen, vielen Jahren,
meine Sicht auf das Thema. Also das das ja das das kann halt man sind auch relativ immun äh äh dadurch, dass dass wir halt.
Jahrzehnten äh schon schon immer irgendwie mit mit Fehlinformationen.
Zu kämpfen haben und mit Leuten, die uns manipulieren äh wollen, zu kämpfen haben. Insofern
hat sich da auch so eine, so ein gewisses Immunsystem, glaube ich, in den, in vielen Köpfen entwickelt, aber das ist auch nicht überall auf der Welt,
so ähm und
natürlich gerade in so Situationen, wenn es sowieso politisch ein Konflikt ist äh oder in in Themen, wo jetzt verschiedene Volksgruppen sowieso sich nicht leiden können und wenn man da dann noch äh für gilt
anfängt irgendwo ja für Probleme zu sorgen, dann finde ich
nicht akzeptabel, nicht tolerierbar.
Nee, das ist auch nicht. Gut, ähm das ist.
Noch zu einem vorletzten äh vorverletzten Thema kommen. Ist eigentlich eine kurze Sache. Äh die Studie von äh Christian Drosten und seinem Team an der Charité.
Zur ähm Untersuchung von.
Infektiösität des Virus ist äh herausgekommen. Da hat er ja im Prinzip schon lange dran gearbeitet. Das ist so diese diese erste Aufregerstudie gewesen oder äh Studie war's ja am Anfang nichts. Es war ja eher so ein so der Beginn einer Studie.
Wo sie die ganzen Proben, die durch die Charité durchlaufen, die PCR-Proben durchgetestet haben, um mal zu gucken, okay, wie viel Virus ist denn jetzt wirklich drin und gibt's da Unterschiede zwischen Kindern? Und Erwachsenen.
Und schon zu Beginn waren ja die Ergebnisse, die vorläufigen Ergebnisse so waren ja so, na ja, man kann.
Sieht hier nicht, dass es jetzt irgendwie bei den Kindern sehr viel anders wäre. Und damals hatten wir noch so diese Debatte mit sind denn,
Schulen überhaupt gefährlich. Und die Kinder werden ja nicht krank und vielleicht geht ja von den Kindern auch überhaupt gar kein
Problem aus und dann kam irgendwie noch die Bild-Zeitung und hat wieder äh Action gemacht gegen Drosten und das war ja dann einfach so eine äh Aufregerzeit, wo wir dann auch gleich wieder gesehen haben, ne, wie das eben so ist mit so Medien, die na ja, nicht eigentlich nur Bericht, sondern,
ehrlich ist auch äh eine Agenda.
Verfolgen, zumindest so eine so eine strategische Agenda, wie sie es halt immer machen, ne, Leute hochjubeln, äh Feinde aufbauen und so weiter und immer im richtigen Moment jubeln und im richtigen Moment drauf hauen
ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste und vor allem ohne Rücksicht auf konkrete wirklich wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse.
Diese Studie scheint jetzt fertig zu sein. Es ist veröffentlicht worden,
relativ aufwendig. Sie haben fünfundzwanzigtausend PCR Proben von positiv getesteten Personen analysiert und haben in diesen Proben.
Die Viruslast bestimmt. Also so mal geguckt, wie viel ist denn da jetzt eigentlich wirklich drin?
Immer so ein bisschen schwierig, weil natürlich ist auch sehr von der Probenentnahme abhängt, aber ich schätze mal, das sind so Faktoren, die sie durchaus offen haben, zeigt sie auch gleich nochmal bei den Kindern.
Und im Wesentlichen ist so ihre Schlussfolgerung, dass es bei Leuten im Alter von zwanzig bis fünfundsechzig.
Keine Unterschiede gibt.
Warum das jetzt bei fünfundsechzig endet, aber das war jetzt zumindest die Aussage und ähm bei Kindern von null bis fünf.
Sie generell zwar geringere Viruslasten,
festgestellt haben, aber auch gleich zu bedenken geben, dass äh einerseits die Viruslast nicht linear mit der Infektion geht, sondern dass es da sozusagen an der Stelle auch nochmal eine Logarithmische äh Geschichte.
Und man auch bedenken muss,
Bei kleinen Kindern sind kommen auch kleinere Tupfer zum Einsatz et cetera und von daher hat man's auch grundsätzlich schon mal bei der Abnahme mit kleineren Mengen zu tun. Das haben sie dann irgendwie
umgerechnet nach ihren Schlüsseln und sind zu dem Entschluss gekommen, dass die Viruslast bei äh diesen ganz kleinen Kindern äh nur so bei achtzig Prozent der Erwachsenen liegen.
Das hat aber dann für die Infektion unterm Strich eigentlich keine nennenswerte Unterschied. Das heißt, man kann einfach davon ausgehen, es ist halt einfach bei Kindern und Erwachsenen im Wesentlichen gleich.
Das ist ja irgendwo auch ich meine vor dieser Pandemie war so das wiederkehrende Meme immer so oh ja ich habe äh Kinder in der Kita, ich bin irgendwie jede Woche erkältet.
Ja. So ähm außerdem haben sie noch gefunden, dass neun Prozent der Proben.
Eine extrem hohe Viruslast aufweisen.
Und interessanterweise sind von diesen neun Prozent hatten die äh Personen.
Von denen diese Proben stammen, hatte ein Drittel keine oder leichte Symptome.
Ja? Und das sind sie sozusagen, unsere Superspreader. Leute, die von ihrer Infektion nichts merken.
Aber irgendwie mit einem Superhai, äh also extrem hohe Viruslast, das war ja irgendwas im Milliardenbereich, also wirklich, es gibt Leute, da breitet sich das Virus enorm aus, aber es scheint ihnen irgendwie nix äh zu tun.
Ja und das sind sie so, die
die Superspreader. Ganz nebenbei haben sie halt auch noch die äh Varianten mal gegeneinander verglichen, also den Wildtyp und B eins eins sieben
und haben festgestellt, dass bei B eins eins sieben im Schnitt mit einer zehnfachen Viruslast zu rechnen ist.
Das ist sicherlich ein Teil der Erklärung, warum äh B eins eins sieben so viel ansteckender ist.
Löse einfach mehr Virus im Rachen.
So und da kommt's raus und deswegen verbreitet es sich. Diese zehnfache Viruslast ist aber jetzt nicht mit zehnfacher.
Ansteckungsfähigkeit zu rechnen, sondern sie reden von einer zwei Komma sechsfachen Infektiösität.
Was ja auch schon mal ganz ordentlich ist, ne. Ja, das war so die Studie.
Ja, interessante Ergebnisse auf jeden Fall, was halt bedeuten würde, dass wir ungefähr sagen, drei Prozent der Infizierten potentielle Superspreader äh äh sind, wenn sie sich nicht von anderen fernhalten.
Ja
Und dann gab's noch ganz frisch, das kam irgendwie auch erst heute, glaube ich, raus oder gestern. Ähm.
Paper, was ähm ein ganz sensitiven Bereich anschaut. Und zwar.
Hatten wir ja diese ganze Debatte um das ist eben diese Sinus äh Wind Thrombosen beziehungsweise generell einfach immun.
Reaktionen im Körper auslöst, in seltenen Fällen,
die unter anderem zu diesen Sinuswellen-Trambosen führen können oder generell halt einfach zu Thrombosen, also Blutverklumpungen im Körper, die man nicht haben will. Und.
Jetzt gibt's halt ein Paper, was ähm wohl eine.
Erklärung dafür hat, warum das bei diesen Vektor Impfstoffen auftreten.
Könnte, tut. Ähm.
Und so ganz nebenbei auch, warum das wahrscheinlich bei den MRNA Impfstoffen aus Prinzip nicht so ist. Und.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das richtig verstanden. Ich versuche das mal so ein bisschen herzuleiten, weil das ist dann nämlich äh mal wieder so ein kleiner Exkurs in ähm in.
Bio, Bio, weißt du, Biologie, Bio.
Mhm.
Und nur Biologie, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man den Bereich nennt, G-Technik, was auch immer. Auf jeden Fall kurz nochmal zurück zu dem Virus. Also.
Asra ist ein Vektor Impfstoff, das heißt der eigentliche Bauplan, den man äh haben will, ist äh in DNA verborgen in.
In einem Vektor Virus. Also in diesem Adeno Virus, den kriegt man dann injiziert.
Ausgeschaltet, der kann sich nicht replizieren. Der dient nur dazu, dass er eben mit seinem.
Halt ein Virus ist, hat das Ding einfach Fähigkeiten in die Zellen reinzukommen.
Kommt in die Zellen rein, spuckt da seine Virus-DNA aus. Die wird dann abgelesen.
Von dem normalen Zellmechanismus, der sieht so, oh ja, hier DNA, da gibt's doch bestimmt was zu replizieren
und dann wird es halt abgelesen und dann wird RNA erzeugt und diese RNA geht vom Zellkern über in.
Zytoplasma, die eigentliche Zelle und dort geht dann halt dieser Produktionsprozess.
Voran und es entsteht dann halt dieses Bike-Protein, was dann auf den Zellwänden, wie das so schön heißt, präsentiert wird und dann kommt das Immunsystem und sagt so, ha, wie was ist das denn hier?
Äh da da müssen wir mal einen Riegel vorschieben. Ne, das ist sozusagen die die Funktionsmethode, wie das tatsächlich funktioniert.
Dieses.
Blesen der DNA und das Erzeugen von RNA ist äh natürlich, wie sollte es auch anders sein, ein relativ komplexer Prozess. Und tatsächlich äh werden da so zwei.
Schritte unter.
Das erste ist die sogenannte Transkription, das ist das eigentliche auslesen der DNA.
Ja? Da wird aber in dem Schritt wird nicht direkt diese RNA erzeugt, wie ich das gerade erzählt habe.
Sondern das ist ein man spricht von der Transkription, also das Ablesen quasi.
Und der.
Das wird also quasi noch eine Zwischenstufe erzeugt, die dann eigentlich erst in die eigentliche RNA überführt wird. Das heißt, diese Transkription, dieser erste Schritt.
Erzeugt eine sogenannte Prä-MRNA.
Das ist im Wesentlichen dieselbe Information, die besteht aber aus so zwei verschiedenen Bereichsarten, den sogenannten Exonz.
Den sogenannten Intronz. Habe ich auch vorher noch nie gehört.
Ja? Also nochmal, DNA kommt rein, Transkription findet äh statt. Es wird also abgelesen und dann wird erstmal eine Prä-MRNA erzeugt und die besteht eben aus diesen zwei Bereichen.
Sind das, was man eigentlich haben will, das sind die sogenannten kodierenden Bereiche, also das ist das, wo die eigentliche MR, Informationen, die man haben will, äh drin steht.
Ja, also die Information mit deren Hilfe Proteine erzeugt werden.
Genau, das ist sozusagen der der Nutzteil, ne?
Der dann sozusagen die Anleitung für die die Teile, mit denen dann halt auch Protein Biosynthese betrieben wird. Und der andere Rest ist, hm, ja.
Genau. Und dann ist aber in diesem Schritt ist das sozusagen unterbrochen von so Intros. Du hast also immer so.
Exons, Intronce, Econs, in Trance, Extronce, Intros und das sind so eine Art Spleißstellen, nennt man das. Das sind so.
Man könnte vielleicht auch sagen, soll Bruchstellen oder so Schaltstellen, äh das sind so, na ja, so optionale.
Trennmomente
Also, nochmal Transkription liest die DNA raus und die eigentliche Information, die da drin steht, die äh bildet sich in ab und diese sind unterbrochen dann von,
Introns. Also es sind sozusagen so Marker bestimmte Stellen, so könnte man sich das, glaube ich, erstmal merken, die einfach so Bruchstellen markieren. Ja?
Und äh der normale Vorgang ist aber dann schon so, dass die einfach genommen werden. Diese werden dann alle zusammengeschoben. Die Introns werden einfach weggeschmissen und dann hast du sozusagen die RNA, die du haben willst.
Jetzt gibt es aber in unserem Körper eine Funktionalität, die als Alternatives Spleißen.
Verstanden wird, ne? Also es bleist, man kennt das so ein bisschen, da sind wir dann doch wieder in der Computer äh Technologie, vor allem in der Netzwerktechnologie, wenn so zwei Glasfaserpaare miteinander verbunden werden. Das nennt man ja auch spleißen, ne? Da werden die sozusagen so zusammen äh erhitzt und das Glas
läuft zusammen, damit es irgendwie eins wird, damit das Licht da ordentlich durchgehen kann.
Und so funktioniert das im Prinzip in dieser Stufe dann auch, wenn denn diese eigentliche Übersetzung gemacht wird, dann werden eben diese Exons zusammengesteckt und diese äh Marker werden weggeworfen.
Aber da steckt durchaus nochmal eine eine Alternative drin,
Das heißt, der Körper kann auf Basis von Informationen oder auch nur von Zufall,
entscheiden, bestimmte Exons einfach wegzulassen. An, das heißt, wenn da so ein so ein Marker ist, kann es auch sein, dass es eben nicht mit dem nächsten exonne weitergeht, sondern dass auch mal eine Information rausgeworfen wird,
einfach so
Und es hat unter anderem den Grund, dass darüber so diese Proteinproduktion reguliert wird, also wenn schon zu viel von dem erzeugt wird, dann kann das System darüber quasi die Proteinproduktion regulieren.
Aber und das scheint auch so zu sein, dass es sich hierbei um einen generellen ähm Kombinationsvorgang handelt,
und man geht davon aus, dass ungefähr die Hälfte unserer Gene, die jetzt also normal unsere Gene sind, im Chromosom abgelegt sind.
Diesem alternativen unterliegen. Das heißt, aus dem selben Gehen kann in so einem Vorgang mal das eine Protein,
aber auch mal ein anderes oder ein modifiziertes Protein erzeugt werden.
Das ist so ein ganz normaler Vorgang, um einfach Varianten zu erzeugen. Das heißt, du hast so verschiedene
ausgeprägte Proteinvarianten, die der Körper mal so und mal so und mal so erzeugt, aber immer auf Basis der selben Gene.
Das heißt, da selbst die Genininformationen, die wir ja so ein bisschen so als so die Grund digitale Information und die nicht änderbare Information und die möglichst immer perfekt äh kopiert werden sollte.
Ja? Das haben wir so im Kopf, aber sieht eher so aus, als ob es sich um etwas handelt, was ohnehin vom Körper frei interpretiert wird, aber auch nicht
komplett frei und nicht komplett rennen, weil da käme ja nur Quatsch bei raus, sondern dafür sind dann eben diese Introns, diese Spleißstellen, die da drin sozusagen äh implizit mit,
kodiert sind, die sind dafür vorgesehen und das ist etwas, was natürlich auch in diesem Vektor Impfstoff in der Beschreibung dieser RNA.
Die man letztlich haben will, sind halt auch solche Introns mit drin. Das gehört einfach dazu, weil man muss das so beschreiben, sonst funktioniert dieser ganze Vorgang nicht.
Sieht es so aus, als ob bei Asra Senica und sie haben sich das wohl,
im Detail angeschaut, wo denn jetzt dieses Bleis stellen tatsächlich sind, ja und dann
quasi so kombiniert so, okay, was kann denn jetzt dabei rauskommen, wenn bestimmte äh Stellen dann übersprungen werden, wenn bestimmte Exons einfach weggelassen werden? Was kommt denn dann dabei raus?
Und dabei haben sie festgestellt, dass es wohl sein kann, dass in seltenen Fällen.
Nicht die RNA erzeugt wird, die die Spike Proteine erzeugt, die wir ja gerne haben wollen. Von dem Virus, damit er vom Immunsystem erkannt wird, sondern eine Variante von diesem Spike Protein
was sich in der Zelle etwas anders verhält. Und das äußert sich dann so, dass dieses Bike Protein nicht einfach an der Zellwand so.
Äh präsentiert wird, so hier gucke mal, Immunsystem, hier ist Bike-Protein, guck dir das mal an, ist irgendwie voll scheiße, da musst du mal was gegen Unternehmen, sondern es kann halt sein, dass es so eine Variante gibt dabei, äh die bezeichnet das als lösliches Protein,
hat also sozusagen,
eine andere Bindungsfähigkeit oder so, keine Ahnung, ob ich jetzt noch die richtigen Begriffe benutze, aber so stelle ich mir das in etwa vor. Und es ist in der Lage, die Zelle zu verlassen und in die Blutbahn zu gehen.
Also die Dinger werden dich einfach präsentiert, sondern die werden quasi in den Körper reingeworfen. Und schwimmen da jetzt rum.
Und das kann dann wiederum zu diesen Immunreaktionen führen. Das ist äh die die These und Prinzip die kurze Geschichte meiner langen Geschichte.
Meinem Versuch hier biologische Prozesse zu beschreiben, obwohl ich von Biologie.
Tut mir keine Ahnung. Mein ganzes Basiswissen Biologie habe ich irgendwie äh in den letzten zwölf, fünfzehn Monaten irgendwie um Faktor achthundert gesteigert.
Ja
War das nachvollziehbar irgendwie?
Also es ist wirklich ein interessanter Vorgang. Also erstmal dieses alternative Speisen. Also wir haben wirklich in unserem Körper so ein System, was so quasi,
nach gutdünken oder random oder nach irgendwelchen externen Steuerfaktoren einfach dieselbe Information mal so und mal so äh interpretiert und wo es einfach verschiedene Varianten erzeugt werden und es kann sein, dass jetzt hier durch Zufall.
Durch schlechtes Design, das kann ich nicht beurteilen, inwiefern man sowas vorhersehen kann, es sein kann, dass eben
Dieser Vektor Impfstoff in dem Fall, das mag auch für andere so gelten, mag auch für gelten, mag auch für Johnson Johnson gelten, keine Ahnung. Dass die sozusagen über diese.
Spleißmarker, die da zwangsläufig drin sein müssen, so eine ungünstige Konstellation gewählt haben, dass eben genau dieser Effekt passiert, den man eigentlich nicht haben will.
Nee, kann ich mir, kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, weil ich weiß halt.
So von, ich sage mal
ja als ich mich vor ich glaub weiß ich nicht fünf sechs zehn Jahren oder so als so das Thema auch und so
in Mode kam, ähm dass
das Genom äh jetzt von natürlichen Organismen äh halt kürzer ist, als wenn.
Du jetzt äh einen Organismus nur auf Basis der, ich sage mal, kodierenden ähm.
Funktionen zusammenbaust. Ähm was dazu führt, dass äh diese ja äh
sagen künstlich erzeugten
ähm Proteinsequenzen, die eigentlich genau dasselbe sagen, das ist identische Programm, was eigentlich das identische Ergebnis äh produziert, nur halt
anders in die DNA einge,
eben nicht ineinander verschachtelt. Das macht halt äh solche Organismen weniger lebensfähig. Es ist quasi auch so ein bisschen äh auch einen wiederum einen Kompressionsmechanismus
äh kann man äh kann man sagen, weil eben verschiedene,
ja Abschnitte mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig codieren können, je nachdem wie sie gerade ausgelesen werden, so insofern ja
Klingt das, also das Ganze klingt erstmal plausibel und äh ja.
Mal gucken, was äh Wasser ist. Vor allem, was es auch noch. Äh das hatte ich ja vorhin schon angedeutet, was damit dann auch noch verbunden ist, ist die Erklärung, warum die MRNA Impfstoffe von diesen Problemen nicht betroffen sind.
Weil die keine DNA basierte Beschreibung von dem RNA liefern, was dann im Körper erst erzeugt wird.
Die MR und A Impfstoffe, wie der Name schon sagt.
Liefern als Impfstoff direkt die MRNA, die natürlich dann keine Exorens und äh Introns mehr hat.
Da wird nicht nochmal was rekombiniert, da läuft nicht nochmal ein anderer Prozess an, sondern,
die treten, da sie ja nur in diese Lipidhülle eingehüllt sind, direkt in die Zelle ein, die sinken da einfach rein und dann äh sagen, dann kommt halt irgendwie hier die ähm,
Ja, die Produktionsmaschine, die Proteine, die halt dafür da sind
diese MRNA sich zu schnappen so nach dem Motto hier ich lese hier kommt grade ein hier kommt grade ein Telegram rein ja das muss ich jetzt hier mal rausmorgen. Schnappt sich dann einfach diese MRNA,
Messenger-Kette und rattert die einfach so durch, schnappt sich irgendwelche ähm.
Aminosäuren, die da halt äh rumfliegen und tackert die halt äh in der vorgeschriebenen Variante zusammen und baut dann im Idealfall halt exakt genau dieses Protein. Aber das.
Der Zwischenschritt.
Mit diesem Splising, der findet nur im Zellkern statt. Das findet nur statt, wenn von der DNA per Transkription das abgelesen wird.
Und erst in der zweiten Stufe entsteht diese RNA. Aber die Pfeißer,
und moderner Impfstoffe und zukünftig natürlich auch der. Die bringen im Prinzip die Bauanleitung
fertige Bauanleitung schon direkt in die Zelle, lassen den Zellkern komplett links liegen und sagen einfach, hier ist fertig, mach mal.
Das ist eigentlich ein totales Wunder. Also umso mehr ich irgendwie über diese diese Technologie lerne, umso geiler finde ich sie.
Naja, ja es ist auf jeden Fall, ich sage mal, ein.
Eine äh Variable oder ein ein Prozess weniger, der schiefgehen kann bei den MRN A Impfstoffen gegenüber den Vektor Impfstoffen.
Ja
was natürlich langfristig äh bedeuten könnte, dass man wahrscheinlich Vektor-Impfstoffe äh ja sich nicht durchsetzen.
Werden möglicherweise langfristig werden sie weil ich wüsste jetzt nicht welche, naja gut der einzige Vorteil bei Vektor-Impfstoffen ist, dass sie sich noch günstiger wohl herstellen lassen. So, also
billiger sind, aber,
Das wird sich, ich sage mal, wahrscheinlich auch äh ändern jetzt mit mehr Produktionskapazitäten und Massenproduktionen und so sicherlich schlichtweg auch einfach der Preis da auch noch runtergehen bei den
MRNA, Impfstoffen, insofern, ja. Bin ich gespannt.
Das denke ich auch, das denke ich auch, dass das äh äh sich abzeichnet. Mal von der Variabilität dieser Technologie nochmal ganz abgesehen. Da geht's ja nicht nur um Impfstoffe, das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach besprochen.
Können wir das abschließen. Ähm.
Ja, dann, was habe ich hier noch? So eine leicht beunruhigende äh Notiz, ähm fand ich ganz noch interessant. Wir haben ja diese.
Diesen Covid-Ausbruch in Indien
Da geht's ja äh wild zur Sache. Ich habe jetzt die Zahlen, ehrlich gesagt, grade gar nicht so richtig verfolgt, ob die das äh geschehen jetzt in den letzten Wochen ein wenig in den Griff bekommen haben.
All die Zahlen gehen runter in Indien gerade.
Hat sich aber auf jeden Fall ein anderes Problem noch parallel gezeigt.
Und zwar dass äh parallel zu dem Infektionsgeschehen auch sehr viele Leute an einer.
Ähm Pilzerkrankung ähm gestorben sind.
Äh weiß nicht, fünftausend Fälle, da war jetzt die Rede, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob das fünftausend ähm Erkrankungen waren oder fünftausend Tote. Ich,
fast vorstellen letzteres und das ist wirklich sehr interessant, weil das ist so ein so ein so ein Pilz, der ähm
Na ja, so ein Schimmelpilz, den man sich einfach so eintreten kann, den man einatmet und so weiter, der so rumfliegt und so Pilze halt. Die sind ja auch irgendwie überall, sonst äh
ne, sonst gäb's ja hier irgendwie uns alle auch nicht
Pilze sind ja an sich eine auch eine eine tolle Sache. Und ich muss sagen, der Tag, an dem ich verstanden habe, dass Pilze keine Pflanzen sind, das war für mich irgendwie auch sehr
es ist irgendwie auch so eine äh Sache, die man, glaube ich, nicht so ohne Weiteres im Kopf hat, weil es liegt ja im selben Gemüseregal, ne. Äh wir sind,
schränkt. Auf jeden Fall ist das ein hochgefährlicher Pilz und man fragte sich halt, warum denn das jetzt gerade so ein Problem ist? Und das ist halt so.
Äh auch so in die Nasennebenhöhlen eindringen kann und sich dann äh innerhalb kürzester Zeit durch Knochen, Nerven und Blutgefäße frisst, so bis ins Gehirn,
Mykose nennt man das.
Und das ist vor allem deshalb jetzt so problematisch, weil im Rahmen der ganzen Überlastung des medizinischen Systems in Indien auch die Medikamente gegen Pilzerkrankungen knapp werden.
Und äh es verbreitet sich auch ein bisschen, das äh gibt wohl auch in Pakistan Bangladesh, Butan, die haben alle irgendwie dasselbe äh Problem. Und diese Schimmelpilz-Erkrankung ist halt normalerweise durchaus händelbar,
aber die floriert halt so richtig in dem Moment, wo halt die Immunsysteme ohnehin schon geschwächt sind.
So dass halt Leute, die mit Covid zu kämpfen haben, dann parallel sich irgendwie auch noch diesen Virus reinpfeifen und dann quasi so zwei Angriffsvektoren haben, ne.
Werk klingt klingt gruselig dieser dieser Pilz äh auf auf jeden Fall ja.
Ja, Diabetes ist wohl auch noch in wenigen weit verbreitet, so eine unkontrollierte Diabetes, das ist äh auch nicht hilfreich. Und äh es werden, wird wohl auch relativ viel Cortison genommen äh genommen und das ist
dann auch ein bisschen das Immunsystem runter, also es ist alles irgendwie nicht gut so und so richtig
Böse ist es halt auch noch, weil der wächst dann auch noch ganz schmerzlos in dir, weil er irgendwie alle nerven, denen er so begegnet, sofort zerstört, bevor die sich überhaupt beschweren können. So, also ist wirklich.
Schlimm.
Ja. Ja.
Weiß ich gar nicht, warum ich das überhaupt am Ende noch gebracht habe, um um irgendwie die die Laune runterzuziehen.
Ja. Gut. Kann man vielleicht schon mal sagen, dass es in in Deutschland zum Glück äh sehr selten,
ist ähm wohl diese Erkrankung bisher oder generell eben sehr seltenes, aber äh ja.
Also klingt nicht so, als wären wir irgendwie uns jetzt bei uns allzu sehr dafür davor fürchten müssen.
Gut, das bringt uns ans Ende der Sendung Pavel.
Mhm. Ja.
Fazit, Ausblick, gute Laune.
Black. Ja, also.
Im Moment auf jeden Fall sehr schön, dass die Zahlen schneller sinken äh als äh ja äh überhaupt,
ja im im seit der ersten Welle oder seit seit wir vernünftig irgendwie.
Zahlen erfassen. Und äh ja, das ist also.
Deutlich erfreulicher als ich das das erwartet hatte und es ist auch da noch keine Verlangsamung
wirklich in Sicht auch sogar der der R-Wert,
geht halt weiter nach unten, das ist alles sehr erfreulich weniger erfreulich ist, dass die Zahl der Toten sich immer noch auf einem hohen Niveau von über tausend.
Bewegt äh pro Woche.
Genau und äh ja insofern wär's nur zu wünschen, wie du vorhin auch sagtest, dass hoffentlich diese Situation noch ein paar Wochen.
Anhält. Ähm ja hm und ansonsten ja die.
Fakten deuten aber alle darauf hin, dass eine neue weitere,
Welle eine vierte Welle. Hm, wahrscheinlich ist äh im Moment. Also wahrscheinlicher als keine.
Vierte Welle und äh ja, dass uns die halt dann so äh im August äh ungefähr,
erreichen wird und dass wir schon ja im im Juni, Mitte, Ende Juni
ersten äh äh Anzeichen. Wahrscheinlich sehen müssten, also potenziell in der zweiten Junihälfte eigentlich steigende Zahlen sehen müssten. Ich hoffe nicht, dass das passiert.
Ähm hoffe, dass irgendwie noch jetzt ja wir irgendwas noch nicht verstanden.
Haben ähm und das dafür sorgt, dass die Zahlen weiter runtergehen, aber nach all dem, was wir verstanden haben, ähm.
Müsste uns eigentlich eine vierte Welle äh bevorstehen.
Aber unser Unwissen könnte uns noch helfen. Oh Mann.
Ja, ja.
Ah, ich habe keinen Bock auf noch eine Welle, ey, echt so gar nicht, überhaupt nicht, ey.
Nee, nee.
Jetzt alle schön zu euren Impfterminen. Wir machen jetzt hier mal so fünfundachtzig, neunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent und dann dann umstellen wir einfach diese Bekloppten. Und dann wird alles.
Ja. Also die sagen die,
die Impfungen, ja äh sind halt ja Impfungen und Wetter sind halt jetzt im Moment die beiden Sachen, die uns noch entgegenkommen.
So. Äh Sommer wird halt entscheidend werden und wenn wir's im Sommer nicht schaffen
irgendwie das Ganze unter Kontrolle zu halten, dann wird es im Herbst und Winter auch nochmal.
Sehr unschön werden, zumal sich jetzt äh ja bewahrheitet, ich muss sagen
du du erinnerst dich, als wir darüber geredet haben, wie viel denn noch jetzt von den Varianten zu erwarten ist und ob wir denn jetzt schon
äh quasi.
Durch haben.
Wir schon alle durch haben, ob's noch irgendwie was besseres als B eins eins sieben geben kann oder ob
äh und da war ja eben auch Christian Drosten immer eigentlich so von Anfang an so
ähm eher wir na ja mit den Varianten und so, das ist äh eigentlich ist das Virus relativ stabil und äh ja und hat jetzt auch seinen Suchraum quasi schon erschöpft, was die Mutation,
angeht und äh einiges unvorstellbar, dass wir noch was Ansteckenderes als B eins eins sieben äh kriegen.
So habe ich ihn nicht verstanden. Also äh also es ist weniger, dass man nicht den Varianten noch zutraut irgendwie etwas besser zu können.
Es ist mehr ein.
Wir werden das trotzdem mit Impfstoffen besiegen können. Es ist nicht so, dass es sich irgendwie komplett von unserem, von unserer Gegen äh Wehr entfernt.
Nee, das ist.
War ja auch schon mit B eins eins sieben im Prinzip so der der Schluss. Aber du hast natürlich Recht, es ist äh aber er hat ja auch immer gesagt.
Weiß man nicht oder kann man nicht sicher sagen, sondern es es könnte sein, dass es, es zeichnet sich ab und auch die indische Variante ist ja wieder nix anderes, als nur so eine Rehkombination der Mutation, die wir bisher auch gesehen haben, ja?
Aber sie ist, sie ist offenbar ansteckender, deutlich ansteckender nochmal als B eins eins sieben und.
Sie hat halt so ein bisschen Immun-Escape.
Features auf jeden Fall. Das heißt, sie ermöglicht zumindest dann zu einem größeren Teil die Reinfektion äh von Leuten, die schon mal die andere Variante hatten,
und ähm sie äh führt dazu, dass
also manche Varianten führen dazu, dass manche Impfstoffe nicht funktionieren, so würde ich das äh sagen. Bisher ist es hauptsächlich nur von Astrasinecker äh bekannt, aber äh offensichtlich, ja, Sinovak oder auch.
War das jetzt bei auf den Seyschellen, hm?
Genau, Sinophan, mit dem Saal, das deutet darauf hin, so ja, dass dass diese Varianten äh doch
also dass die Natur da doch noch einiges in petto hat und wir tatsächlich
einfach nicht wissen, äh was da noch an Varianten auf uns zukommen kann. Vielleicht ist jetzt
die äh diese indische Variante jetzt das Ende der Fahnenstange vielleicht auch nicht so.
Also wir müssen uns, glaube ich, ohnehin mal die chinesischen Impfstoffe nochmal genauer anschauen, aber auch in Chile kommt ja einer äh zum Einsatz, nämlich äh von Sinovak, dieser Coronavak. Ähm
Und ich glaube, kann Sino auch noch, also,
und äh Chile hat ja auch eine extrem äh starke Impfkampagne, die sind äh uns noch weit voraus, aber haben gerade auch äh extrem explodierende Inzidenzen wieder, ne, also die sind da so auf einem ähnlichen Pfad wie äh Indien das war.
Und von daher, das bestätigt das natürlich, das der Kampf ist noch nicht komplett geworden.
Und was mich halt ärgert äh ist, dass es halt jetzt nicht nur mit Ansage.
Grade. So, sondern äh dass wir grade auch.
Äh äh dabei ähm versagen die Varianten
davon abzuhalten, sich global zu verbreiten.
Also im Grunde genommen, wenn wir jetzt eine vierte Welle kriegen, dann ist es eigentlich äh die dritte Pandemie
die wir jetzt in Folge äh durchmachen, ja. Das sind halt eigentlich äh sind das neue Viren
oder zumindest klar es gibt 'ne gewisse Kreuzimmunität auf jeden Fall völlig kein völlig neuer,
Erreger, aber ähm ja und wenn du dir anguckst zum Beispiel, was mich halt.
Einfach tierisch aufgeregt hat, ist, dass wenn jetzt Leute einreisen aus Risikogebieten, dann ist die,
Regelung so. Mh.
Also erstmal Ausländer aus Risikogebieten dürfen ja praktisch nicht rein, aber für jetzt deutsche oder Europäer, die halt nach Hause zurückkehren wollen, äh aus Risikogebieten
ist es so, dass die dann einen Test brauchen und sich dann anschließend
in häusliche Quarantäne begeben müssen für vierzehn Tage, ja. Was äh aber nachweislich dazu geführt hat, in Berlin gab's da mehrere Fälle, dass diese Leute einfach
dann äh ihre Mitbewohner angesteckt haben mit den neuen Varianten.
Und ja, das ist das, das finde ich einfach, dass wir nichts daraus gelernt haben, so, dass wir nach wie vor die,
ja Maßnahmen haben für Einreisende, die ja schlichtweg.
Unzureichend sind, die schlichtweg und der Hintergrund, warum das so ist, dass das
also ist jetzt 'ne Vermutung aber warum man das so gemacht hat ist dass ansonsten die Alternative wäre halt Hotel Quarantäne. Wer einreist wird erstmal komplett von der Bevölkerung
isoliert und wird wird dafür gesorgt, dass ja der eben keine Mitbewohner ansteckt, aber sowas kostet halt tausendfünfhundert bis zweitausend Euro. So und.
Das würde halt bedeuten und das ist halt vor allem so ein Ding dann auch potenziell für Dienstreisende
äh so, wenn äh weil dann müsste ja Arbeitgeber nämlich die Hotel Quarantäne bezahlen plus irgendwie noch Geld äh ähm also dem dem Mitarbeiter wahrscheinlich auch noch dafür bezahlen, wenn der vierzehn Tage in irgendeinem Hotel in Quarantäne sitzen
muss und ja muss halt Gehalt weiter bezahlt werden und wenn man jetzt so das heißt es ist halt mal wieder ja
Wirtschaft, Wirtschaftsinteressen, so die dazu führen, dass halt ja
notwendige Sicherheitsmaßnahmen nicht ergriffen
äh werden. So, das ist für uns, dass wir jetzt, also wenn wir äh äh dann in diese vierte Welle reingehen, gut, äh sagen, ja gut, vielleicht lässt sich's eh nicht vermeiden, ja? Wir kriegen's eh nicht dicht
äh so, aber
ja aber wir versuchen's nicht mal ja wir versuchen's ja nur völlig herzlich. Anders kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen, dass Leute, die
aus Ländern mit Varianten kommen äh diese Infektionen äh so hier äh mehr oder weniger fast ungehindert reintragen können, ja in die deutsche Bevölkerung
und das äh ja ähm das regt mich auf.
Ja, jetzt haben wir das Ende irgendwie schon wieder, jetzt haben wir wieder keinen positiven äh äh Ausblick fürs Ende.
Kriegst du regelmäßig immer wieder super hin, aber.
Schauen wir einfach noch mal auf die schönen Zahlen, zumindest,
eine Woche mal so durchatmen und so das Gefühl haben, dass alles besser sein könnte, obwohl ich ihm so ein bisschen Angst habe, damit die Leute schon wieder komplett in so einen ach ja, ist ja alles vorbei, Modus zu,
Das sollten wir jetzt langsam mal äh gelernt haben, da sind wir jetzt noch nicht. Und wenn ihr irgendwie ein Interesse an geöffneten Schulen habt und all diesen ganzen Kram.
Heißt es einfach auch, dieser Sommer leider, weil vergeigt im Februar, ja, oder eigentlich schon vergeigt im letzten Oktober, aber nochmal so richtig doppelt mit Ansage und Anlauf äh,
und und und maximaler Demonstration von von von Blödheit äh vergeigt im Februar. Deswegen können wir jetzt keine schönen Sachen haben. Hätten wir jetzt die Inzidenz irgendwie schon so richtig weit unten,
so wie es im letzten Jahr war, müssten wir auch zu dieser vierten Welle nicht keine Angst haben, aber wir werden auf jeden Fall viel besser gerüstet. Und äh wie du schon richtig sagst, wir sind halt auch leider mit den anderen Schutzmaßnahmen nicht so richtig weit, aber.
Im Zweifelsfall könnten wir es ja auch dann im Herbst mal mit einer neuen Regierung probieren.
Ja, ja.
Wäre vielleicht ja auch nochmal eine Variante, weil ich glaube, da ist, da ist auf jeden Fall noch Luft nach oben.
Ja, ich ja, wobei ich da wenig Hoffnung habe, dass.
Ich habe auch wenig Hoffnung, aber es wäre trotzdem eine Option. Ja, es wäre es wäre eine Option und ich glaube, sie sah noch nie so äh interessant aus wie dieses Mal.
Aber wahrscheinlich
Also lass mich gerne gerne überraschen, hängt auch sehr vom Wahlausgang ab, aber beim letzten Mal hat's ja auch, glaube ich, ein halbes Jahr gedauert, bis eine Regierungsbildung äh stattfinden konnte und
ähm bei den aktuellen Konstellationen kann ich mir vorstellen, dass auch Angela Merkel dann noch äh in äh zwanzig
zweiundzwanzig äh noch eine Zeit lang Kanzlerin äh sein wird. Nein, das ist äh es war halt nach der letzten Wahl war es halt auch so
halt dauern wird und ansonsten äh ja, äh.
Merkel oder SARS-CoV zwei, oh Mann.
Ansonsten hat
hat Rot-Grün über der letzten äh Regierung äh haben die halt katastrophale Anfängerfehler auch noch gemacht, die dann halt zehn, fünfzehn Jahre, also zum Beispiel die die Steuerreform war halt die unter rot
Grün war halt ein totaler äh war eine totale Katastrophe, ja. Also die.
G2 und so weiter, aber lass es.
Äh nee, nee, das, das, das auch noch, nee, ich rede jetzt speziell von der Steuerreform, die dazu geführt hat, dass äh wo sich total verrechnet hatten und die dazu geführt hat,
dann also viel von von den Infrastrukturproblemen, äh die wir haben, auch das den Gemeinden Geld fehlte und so überhaupt, ist halt das ist halt auf eine rot-grüne Steuerreform zurück
zurückzuführen auf die und deswegen und das war aber auch so ein Schock äh damals für alle, auch für die für die Beamten in den Ministerien, wie sehr sie sich verrechnet hatten, dass wir halt ja, dass das also.
Seitdem niemand über eine aufgefallen, dass seit langem niemand mehr über eine große, umfassende
Steuerreform redet, seit ungefähr zehn Jahren sich erinnern, da war irgendwie das damals das Thema irgendwie Steuererklärung auf dem Bierdeckel und weiß ich nicht was. Äh das war so die Phase
Ja und dann ist das komplett in die Hose gegangen und seitdem hat jeder, also die Ministerien, die haben irgendwie
ja die sind traumatisiert von dieser damaligen Steuerreform weil egal.
Ich bin traumatisiert davon, dass es, also jetzt habe ich dreimal versucht, hier irgendwie mit einem positiven äh Ausblick rauszugehen. Ich lasse es jetzt einfach sein.
Nein, aber ich hatte, ich ich hatte aber noch, hatte ich nicht noch einen wichtigen Punkt. Einen haben wir noch, äh den ich, den ich noch.
Erwin äh äh wollte. Ja wir waren, wir waren eigentlich über die Wahlen äh dahin äh gekommen, genau und.
Regierung und so, ja, was was kann die besser machen? So, ich tja.
In Bezug auf die Pandemie, meinst du jetzt.
Ja, ja, ja, also bis die sich also bis bis wir eine neue Regierung haben, äh das das,
dauern können und dann äh ja, je nachdem, wie die also es geht auch schlimmer. Also wenn irgendwie wir einen Laschet als Bundeskanzler äh kriegen, sodass wir halt äh einfach die komplett,
Katastrophe. Ja, also schlimmer.
Schlimmer wird's nicht.
Schlimmer kann's ganz kaum sein.
Aber wir geben jetzt mal hier keine Wahlempfehlungen ab, sondern wir wünschen euch jetzt erstmal,
Wochenende oder wann auch immer ihr diese Sendung hört, bedanken uns sehr fürs Zuhören, weisen nochmal auf den nächsten Dienstag hin, da machen wir wieder unsere Runde auf Clubhaus,
diesmal vergesse ich ihn auch nicht sofort in die Shownotes zu packen. Äh Link auf den Event findet ihr, wenn ihr den anklickt im Browser aufmacht und ihr habt noch keinen Account, könnt ihr euch damit sozusagen selber einladen.
Ja und dann freuen wir uns über Fragen und Feedback zu all dem, was wir jetzt hier erzählt haben oder was sonst dann nächsten Dienstag schon wieder aktuell ist. Ich hoffe, wir können dann immer noch niedrige R-Werte äh anstarren.
Ja und äh insofern würde ich sagen, entlassen wir euch jetzt und äh.
Ja. Darf ich noch.
Erzählen, ne?
Darf ich noch einen Punkt äh erwähnen, kein neues Thema, kein neues Thema, sondern nur äh was mir halt aufgefallen ist, äh auch wieder einer unserer
ähm Prognosen, die wohl eingetreten sind, ich weiß, dass wir als die äh
dritte Welle im Anlaufen war und so war eine Prognose, ja, also bis zehn Sommerferien wird kein vernünftiger Schulunterricht mehr stattfinden und das sieht jetzt ganz so aus gerade, als wenn ja,
die meisten Schulen bis äh zu den äh Sommerferien nicht wieder in Präsenzunterricht zurückkehren werden und
Wenn jetzt unsere anderen Prognosen, nämlich die mit der vierten Welle oder sind ja nicht Prognosen, sondern Befürchtungen, nenne ich mal, unsere Befürchtung, wahr werden. Denn wird's auch ausgerechnet nach den Sommerferien äh wird's dann auch keine lange entspannte
keinen entspannten Präsenzunterricht.
Das war jetzt ein positiver Ausblick oder was zum Schloss.
Äh ja für die, ja, ja, ja, so nach dem Motto, hurra a hurra, die Schule brennt. Ähm.
Schmeiß dich raus. Leute.
Okay, dann macht's gut. Ja, okay, tschau.